Douglas też gar nicht nicht gut, aber du kannst es integral in die Ansprüche machen!
H beter die
Ja, ich war gemutet, das ist richtig, aber ich war absichtlich gemutet.
Zeit für RTX On, ja das habe ich verpasst, die Vorstellung von dem neuen Nvidia Zeug.
Habe ich überhaupt nicht mehr dran gedacht, wann war das? Letzten Dienstag, ne?
Ich habe irgendwann 21 Uhr auf die Uhr gekommen und dachte, oh ist jetzt vorbei.
Aber ich muss sagen, was die, also die haben ja 3000, ich bin ja bei der Benahmung wieder
ein bisschen blickig wieder, irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, ne?
Aber von 1080 Ti, 2080 Ti auf eine 3080 Ti gibt es nicht ohne 3090 und was auch immer.
Zumindest wird es teuer, dafür wird die mittlere Klasse schneller als die alte Highend Klasse
und kostet nur die Hälfte.
Ja, Stripes 007, 14 Monate, oh, excellent subscription, warte mal hier, das ist ja schon
richtig und der Easykiller auch, 11 Monate, das ist ganz knapp noch, ganz knapp nur,
nur, aber bald ist es, die RTX 3080 soll doppelt so schnell sein, ja gut, die erzählen
wir mal ab, aber ich werde mir auf jeden Fall, wenn das jetzt, wenn das denn erhältlich
sein wird irgendwann dieses Jahr noch, also offiziell schon, aber wir wissen ja wie das
ist, wenn es neue Hardware rauskommt, das ist erst mal vorbestellt und danach ist es
ausverkauft und wahrscheinlich kriegst du erst wieder im Februar eine ordentliche Grafikkarte.
Jetzt fehlt plus noch AMD, äh, jetzt fehlt plus noch AMD, 495 leak has appeared, das
haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt, äh, was, nö, nö, das liegt aber, also RTX Voice und
so verwende ich nicht, ich hab's mir noch nicht mal angeguckt, ich muss sagen, ich
finde das Setup so jetzt ganz ok, außerdem bin ich zu faul da dran rum zu basteln, solang
das funktioniert ist ok, ja doch, Shadowplay, Shadowplay, klar, Shadowplay verwende ich
nicht oft, kann man schon vorbestellen, kann man schon irgendwie vorbestellen oder so,
wir verraten euch jetzt schon wo ihr die, wo ihr sie vorbestellen, äh, nein, warum ist
das so teuer, what the fuck, warum ist ne, warum ist ne 2080 Ti so teuer und was ist
das da nebendran, GTF, ah ne, RTX ist ja keine GTX, das ist ja RTX jetzt aber, ne, gibt's
doch nicht, ok, oh guck mal, bunte iGame, na wenn die bunt ist, wenn die bunt ist, dann
bin ich ja, dann ist ja alles gut und da ist die oben, ach, das ist ne Wasserkühlung,
wo ich die Waffe stehe, ups, GearBest China Shop, ja, ich würde auch gerade 3000 Euro
im China Shop ausgeben, der größte, ja Herz390, der Game steht teilweise recht, er schreibt,
der größte Vorteil von Nvidia ist der Nvidia Codec, AMD hat ja was ähnliches aber das
funktioniert nicht so gut, aber was man nicht vergessen darf, das sind einfach die schnellsten
Karten von dem Videocom, ja, das ist natürlich auch ein Vorteil, mag jetzt vielleicht kein
krasses Feature sein, aber einfach die schnellste, schnellere Grafikkarte, dazu haben wir sie
auch nicht verkehrt, was kostet denn der Kram, wenn es rauskommt, 1500 oder sowas, ne, irgendwie
sowas in dem Dreh, PC-Magazin, da hatte ich auch mal früher ein paar Ausgaben gekauft
zum Crap, das war genauso, genauso mies, ne, ok, ne, PC-Welt war schlechter, wurde nur noch
getoppt von einem voll Computer-Bild, ok, zeig mal her, PC-Games-Hardware, den traue ich
immer, ja, was soll es denn kosten, Preis, Preis, seht ihr irgendwo den Preis, ah hier,
ich, BTF, sag mal einfach was Nvidia gesagt hat, ich glaube 1400, ja 1500, hier sonst
offiziell, ok, exzellent, ah, Pounders Edition, heck weh, ah, exzellent, erhältlich ab 24.90,
gar nicht mehr so lange hin, also Leute, wenn ich mir, also, das dumme ist, ja, ich würde
mir gern einen kompletten neuen PC kaufen, dazu fehlen mir aber die CPU, ne ordentliche,
ne neue Ryzen-Generation, so, und, ich überleg mir, ob ich mir jetzt schon eine 30.90 kaufe
und den alten PC einbauen, die Sache ist nämlich die, mein aktueller Rechner ist ja, ist ja
schnell genug, ja, ist ja nicht so als bräuchte ich überhaupt, also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich
mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe, ne, der wird in Spielen nicht selbst, selbst wenn AMD,
der jetzt irgendwann noch Ende des Jahres, ne Ryzen 4950X rausbringt, gehen wir mal von
aus, der ist, keine Ahnung, sind wir mal optimistisch und sagen, der ist 20% schneller als der alte,
dann ist das immer noch plus minus paar Prozent, was man über Takte der 8700K aktuell in Spielen
macht, und ich brauch die Performance nur für Spiele, weil rendern ist schnell genug,
auch mit 6 Kern, ich render ein Video für YouTube upscaled, also wenn ich das upscale
auf 4K, weil mehr Bitrate auf YouTube, render ich das knapp in der Laufzeit von den Videos,
also da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren, einfach weil es geht, ja genau, aber dazu
müsste erstmal AMD beikommen mit den CPUs, naja, wenn ich denn mal YouTube Video rende,
ja, hab ja recht, Exposed, Alter, Exposed, da kann ich 8K hochladen, ja, ja gut, also,
wenn schon, kaufe ich mir so eine, allerdings wird es wahrscheinlich sein, wie immer, dass
die hier deutlich besser zu bekommen ist, wo ist eigentlich der Sinn davon, dass das
vorher rauskommt, dass man 2 Wochen Marketing Hype hat, Moinser auf Jelly, ey, dieser komische
Song, der ist auch überall dabei, egal welcher Playliste, fange zu Wintersemester an Softwareentwicklung
zu studieren, irgendwelche Tipps, ja, sich jetzt schon ein paar Programmiersprachen anzugucken
und so die Basics anzueignen, nein, das kaufen wir jetzt garantiert nicht mehr, ja also dann
sowas da, allerdings wird man die nicht bekommen, es sei denn, es sei denn, man setzt sich,
ich weiß ja nicht wann die das anlocken, es sei denn, man setzt sich hier hin um 0 Uhr
und bestellt eine vor, dieses TM, Alter, die machen immer einfach mal mehr TM hin,
dass keiner irgendwann sagen kann, nach dem Motto, ah, war nicht geschützt, lull, was
wollt ihr mit bunte iGame, China Shops, kann man die China Shops einfach mal wegfiltern,
da haben doch bestimmt schon irgendwelche unseriösen Anbieter den Kram gelistet, ne,
naja, wurscht, aber da wirds mal echt Zeit, neue Hardware, ich brauch den Kram jetzt mal
langsam, auf Banggood und Aliexpress bestimmt, ich bekomm bald ne Lieferung von Banggood,
auf Geizhals ist gelistet, ok, was soll der RTX Ultimate, ne, RTX Premium sein, ach, das
ist irgendein Asus fertig Ding mit Custom Kühler und vielleicht bisschen ab Werk übertaktet
oder so, ne, gut, aber die gibt es ja noch nirgendswo, aber ganz schön alt, 1976, excellent
Subscription, kaufst du denn das Referenzdesign von den Videos, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
kaum, also wenn man die, wenn man die am Anfang nur ordentlich bei Nvidia direkt vorbestellen
kann, dann das, also ich hab jetzt die letzten drei oder vier Grafikkarten nur im Nvidia
Referenzdesign gehabt, na jo, hab keine Schmerzen mit, die sind mittlerweile auch wirklich in
Ordnung, es sei denn, man will ne Wasserkühlung haben, wagt doch Nvidia, ja gut, dazu müsste
ich erst, ich hab ja die letzten drei oder vier Karten, glaub ich, von Nvidia gekriegt,
aber dafür mach ich, ich mach ja grad nix, wenn ich nix mach, lohnt sich das für Nvidia
und ich glaub ich bin jetzt auch zu doof da zu fragen, so nach dem Motto, hallo, krieg
ich ne 2500 Euro Grafikkarte umsonst, ich halt die dann auch mal kurz ins Bild auf ne
Stream, wo es vor der Leute zugucken, glaub das interessiert die nicht so sehr, auf YouTube
war das interessanter, aber da müsste ich halt mal was machen, dass es sich dann wieder
lohnt, ja, beste Grafikkarte, Matrox Minionium G550, ja, Moment, das gibt es noch, die gab's
vor 20 Jahren mal.
Ach gut, ne, ne, ne, ne, also ich muss sagen, ich bin geneigt hier, warte mal, warte mal,
wann warten das, Moment, Moment, wann ist das, 24.
haben die gesagt, Donnerstag, so ein Kacktag, da kann ich noch nicht mal abends um 24 da
muss ich morgens arbeiten gehen.
Was meinen die eigentlich mit verfügbar, meinen die dann, man kann die hier, hat das
schon mal jemand gemacht, also heißt das, wenn die verfügbar sind, dass dann hier ein
kaufen Knopf kommt, ne, einfach von der Arbeit aus bringt ja nix, ich muss ja nachts, wenn
die das hier freischalten um 24 Uhr oder so, muss ich dann hier draufklicken, sonst kriege
ich keine.
Okay, man kann den Kram direkt, ah, Nvidia hier, keine transparenten Bilder, weird Jam,
so geht's ja net, und ich hab die Seite sogar, also das ist kein Dark Reader, die Seite sieht
standardmäßig so hässlich aus, weird Jam Nvidia, ich weiß, dass das keine 3000er sind,
ich wollt gucken, wie das normalerweise im Einkaufen hier aussieht, moin Kengin, so,
ähm, tja, Benachrichtigung brauch ich net, also dann wär ich, hat das jemand schon mal
gemacht, wieviel Uhr schalten die den Kram frei, wann schalten die das frei, 24, 9, 3000,
Facebook, zulul, was haben wir da mit Facebook, currys.co, what, was zum Teufel ist Currys
PC World, außerdem ist das UK, also, das wird folgendermaßen laufen, ich sag euch
jetzt mal, wie es ist, keiner, keiner der Leute, der nicht Ultrakluck hat, wird am 24,
9 eine Grafikkarte bestellen können, so, danach denken die Leute, ah, okay, gehste
guides halt gucken, auch alles ausverkauft, so, dann kommen die ersten Läden, so irgendwie
1-2 Wochen später auf die Idee, die welche haben, verkaufen die für das doppelte, und
es werden sich Leute kaufen, für 2500 Euro, so, ähm, dann ist das wieder weg, weil das
alle gekauft haben, und irgendwann dann Ende des Jahres kannst du, wobei, da kommt Weihnachten,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch nicht Ende des Jahres, vielleicht, vielleicht auch erst nächstes
Jahr, wenn ihr das dann ordentlich kaufen kannst, obwohl es, obwohl es 24, 9. rauskommt,
deswegen fragt einer, ich kenne auch nicht mal, ich kenne niemand mehr bei Nvidia, die
sind alle nicht mehr bei Nvidia, ich wüsste gar nicht, wen ich fragen soll, deshalb, keine
Ahnung, muss auch nicht sein, ich kaufe mir das Ding, dann habe ich da auch keinerlei
Verpflichtungen oder sonst was, schreib ein Programm, das Auto beimacht, das ist eine
exzellente Idee, das Problem ist nur, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Seite aussehen
wird, ich kann das nicht skrippen oder automatisieren, weil ich nicht weiß, wie die Seite aussehen
wird, wobei man sie kaufen kann, naja, wurscht, also wir gucken 24, 9, muss ich mal aufschreiben,
hatten wir schon, 24, 9, Nvidia, so, Event ist das, jetzt fehlt ja echt nur noch eine
neue Ryzen CPU, gibt es da schon irgendwelche Leaks, Leak, so, Moment, es ist 4950x, Leak,
New Leak, naja, das klingt natürlich sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja, das sind ganz tolle,
ganz tolle Sachen, das ist besser, Moment, ich kann auch nicht richtig schreiben, ne, Leak
has appeared, das haben wir uns doch schonmal angeguckt vom 6. August, das ist doch schon
einen Monat alt, das interessiert doch keinen mehr, aber was neues, Neues hier, Tools, Anytime,
eine Woche alt, so, hier, Leak, Leak, also, Might be launching in Oktober, ja, exzellent,
auf gehts, September, Oktober nächsten Monat, exzellent, das wäre gut, das wäre gut, kein
Interesse an einer 3080Ti, es gibt keine 3080Ti, Webarchive vom 2000er Release, das ist eine
gute Idee, können wir mal gucken, wie die Seite zum 2000er Release aussah, Big Brain
Idee Chat, wann war denn 2000er, haben die nicht gesagt es wird keine 3080Ti geben, gut
die sagen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, als ob Nvidia gleiche Seite macht, warum nicht,
20. September 18, oh, guck mal davor gab es die nicht, ja, exzellent, Snapshot, Moment,
September, November, wann, Moment, ach, September, da gibt es die Seite nicht, wie sahen die
hier aus, Webarchive, ja, guck mal, die Seite sah ziemlich, also Leute, guck mal, jeder
der sagt als ob Nvidia die gleiche Seite macht, guckt euch mal die Seite an, sieht die anders
aus, die sieht 2 Jahre später noch genauso aus, 2 pro Kunde, derzeit nicht verfügbar,
ist, vielleicht nicht, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, das ist eine gute Idee, wir
gucken mal, wir gucken mal wie die englische Seite heißt, vielleicht ist es einfach so
Geforce buy ohne irgendwas, ne, ENUS vielleicht, ja, was, ENUS, gibt es nicht
Nope, Denied, mein Browser ist eigentlich auf Englisch, guck mal, ich hab fast alles
auf Englisch, Home Trending Subscriptions, eigentlich mal, das ist Geo, Geo IP mäßig,
naja, wer hätte ich jetzt NordVPN, ja, aber wunderbar, also die Seite sieht genauso aus
im Endeffekt, ich guck mal, 24.9. nachts, Max was macht der Friseur kaputt, leben die
noch, ja mit dem Kaputt war ich gestern Essen, gestern seit 6 Monaten, das erste mal wieder
in Frankfurt und als ich Zug gefahren bin, gab es gleich Stress, weil ein Fahrradfahrer
seine Maske, also der hat keine Maske gehabt und da haben sie gleich Stress gemacht alle,
da ist die richtig Pepega Action am Start gewesen, Video aufgenommen, ja, ne, naja,
und, steht da jetzt irgendein Datum dabei, Oktoberlaunch is almost certain, naja, wie
waren das bei der letzten AMD Ryzen Generation, der 3950X kam ein bisschen später, ne, Release
Date, wann kam der denn raus, Date, hier, ja ok, das ist auf dem Papier, praktisch gesehen
kam der da, kam der da glaube ich nicht raus, neue Tiefstpreise, ok, kostet immer 1000
Euro in dem Dreh, ne, ne, ne, weniger, weniger, glaube 600 oder so, was kostet ein 3000 aktuell,
600, ja, also da muss ich schon sehr viel Glück haben, dass ich mir am Ende des Jahres
einen neuen Rechner bauen kann, ich muss irgendwie eine Grafikkarte bekommen und irgendwie hoffen
dass AMD, jetzt, ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll, also, also, die, die, äh, rationalere
Variante wäre, also die, ne, die Köpfchenvariante wäre eigentlich zu warten, bis eine 3000,
bis dann 3490, äh, 4950X rauskommt, weil das, bis man den ordentlich bekommt, ist es eh
nächstes Jahr, so, und dann kaufe ich mir nächstes Jahr im Februar ganz in Ruhe einen
neuen Rechner, bis dahin gibt es die CPUs dann auch lieferbar, die Grafikkarten lieferbar
und bis dahin gibt es auch halbwegs sinnvolle, äh, 4TB NVMe SSDs, weil aktuell ist das ja
alles nicht so, nicht so sinnvoll, ja, ich, ich will, äh, Samsung hier, es lohnt sich
nicht, so, weil das hier eigentlich, das geht eigentlich hier, kann man sich doch nicht
mal beschweren hier, für den, aber ich glaube hier hatten wir, hier hatten wir schonmal
den Test gelesen und das Problem war, das Problem war, dass die viel zu heiß werden,
ne, hatten wir nicht, haben wir einen Test gelesen, ist 2x2TB vielleicht günstiger,
vielleicht, stimmt, bisschen, ja, bisschen billiger, 100€ oder so, 90€ billiger, aber
und dann könnte, ich brauch ja gar keine 4TB wirklich, ne, also, ich hab aktuell hab
ich ne 2TB SSD und ne 500, also ne NVMe 2TB SSD und ne NVMe 512G SSD und ne 6TB Festplatte,
das reicht ja auch voll und ganz, das reicht ja auch echt dicke, dicke aus und ich dachte
mir halt, wenn ich mein neuer Rechner kauf, dann geh ich mal wieder so voll in die vollen
und mach ne 4TB SSD rein, ne 3900 RTX und ne 4950X Ryzen, so, der ganze Rechner kostet
wahrscheinlich 4000€, aber, haben, ja, naja, wurscht, guck mal, was können wir uns für
Videos angucken, hast du im Stream schon mal nen VPN sauber mit Zugriff auf so lokale
Netzwerke auf, wir haben mal WireGuard gemacht im Stream, wir haben mal WireGuard gemacht,
ist aber schon ewig her, naja, irgendwas, irgendwelche Sachen im Chat übersehen, zeig
mal, naja, Setpudding, ja, Google Vorschläge, teilweise, vor allem seitdem die ganzen China
Shops da auch am Start sind in der Google Shopsuche, ich wart hier aktuell noch auf
ne Lieferung von Banggood, ich hab mir hier ein paar bestellt, weil die irgendeine Aktionswoche
hatten, also die, das sind diese Boards, die wir auch mal zusammen, zusammen im Stream uns
angeguckt, also zusammen gebastelt haben, da haben die hier nämlich grad ne Aktion am
Start gehabt, ähm, eins für die Hälfte quasi, und da hab ich drei Stück bestellt
aus China, überlegen, kost halt nur 3920 versandt, ich glaub ich hab sogar EU Priority
Line gemacht, so, dann bin ich mal gespannt, wann die wirklich ankommen, die Senderverfolgung
ist ein bisschen fail, was Banggood angeht, da steht ja nur so Sachen wie Handled to Aircraft
Carrier, aber ich hab halt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass ein Flugzeugträger meine Pakete
ausfährte, was hältst du von der Sache, wirklich gutes Video, ok, zeig mal, 1000 Betriebssysteme,
100 Betriebssysteme von einem USB Stickbooten, hier können wir uns mal angucken, wenn du
mal mal die
Lames Netz Deutschland hängt beim Ausbau des Glasfasernetzes hinterher, da muss ich mir
keinen Beitrag vom ZDF angucken, das ist so, ja, ich mein, also, allein schon der Titel,
ja, das ist so, und wisst ihr, eine Sache, wo ich mich heute immer noch frage, warum
das nicht mehr Leute einsehen, was diese Sache hier angeht ist, könnt ihr euch noch
an die, an die, ich mein, wann waren das, UMTS Versteigungen, wann waren die UMTS Zeugversteigungen,
ok, das ist, das war 2000, da werden sich wahrscheinlich nicht viele von euch dran erinnern, ja, aber
so im Jahr 2000 rum wurden UMTS Lizenzen, also das 3G ist das glaube ich, wurden UMTS Lizenzen
versteigert, für unglaublich viel Geld und damals war das so, dass man gesagt hat, ich
kann mich daran erinnern, das Land, also nee, das Land, der Staat, Deutschland halt, da
hat damals gesagt, wir versteigern die Lizenzen an Mobilfunkanbieter zum Höchst bieten, ich
glaube 3, 3, ich glaube 3 Anbieter haben die Lizenzen bekommen, letztendlich was sie telekommen,
das, das was dann irgendwann mal E plus wurde und, und das was jetzt Vodafone ist, frag
mich nicht, wie der Kram damals, damals hieß, so, und alle anderen Anbieter wurden quasi
rausgedrängt, also man hat sich komplett die Chance darauf verbaut, dass es vielleicht
mal mehr als 2, 3 große Anbieter gibt und das Problem dabei war nur, dass die Anbieter
Milliarden bezahlt haben für UMTS Lizenzen, dementsprechend was macht ein Anbieter, der
Milliarden für UMTS Lizenzen bezahlt hat, der wird erstmal nur dort ausbauen, wo es
besonders lukrativ ist, also du baust vielleicht in der Stadt UMTS aus, aber du baust nicht
auf dem Land UMTS aus, deswegen haben wir heute noch so viele Mobilfunklücken, dass
wir heute noch so viele Mobilfunklücken haben, liegt meiner Ansicht nach zum größten Teil
an der UMTS Versteigung, hätten die, meiner Ansicht nach, so retrospectivisch, ja, exzellent
Big Brain Wort, ähm, hätte man das anders machen sollen, man hätte, man hätte das
den Anbietern geben sollen, ich weiß nicht, ob man es ihnen hätte umsonst geben sollen,
was weiß ich, aber angenommen, man hätte es den Anbieter umsonst gegeben, aber nur
dem Anbieter, oder den Anbietern, die sich verpflichten, und wir reden jetzt hier nicht
von so, so diese, so diese, diese Lari, Wischiwaschi-Verpflichtung, so nach dem Motto, bis 2077,
musst du sonst was machen, nee, nur den Anbietern geben, die sich verpflichten, ordentlich auszubauen,
kontrolliert, ordentlich, jedes Jahr gucken, dass die das einhalten, wenn die das nicht
einhalten, auch keine Strafe bezahlen, sondern mit Androhung einfach Lizenzen entziehen,
bäm, weil dann hätten die keine Chance gehabt, das nicht auszubauen, ja, ähm, so, und, dann
hätten wir deutlich bessere, was zumindest was Mobilfunk angeht, deutlich bessere, ähm,
Netzabdeckung, weil die Anbieter, denen hätte, denen wäre gar keine andere Wahl geblieben,
erstens hätten die Milliarden gespart an UMTS Lizenzen, und zweitens hätten die ausbauen
müssen, und die Schweiz kriegt das auch besser hin, es kriegt das, es kriegt das, die meisten
Länder kriegen das besser hin, die meisten, sag mal mal, nicht unbedingt dritte Weltländer
kriegen das besser hin, und sogar manche dritte Weltländer kriegen das besser hin,
ja, ähm, das war, das war eine bescheuerte Idee, und ich weiß noch damals, hatten das
alle geil, damals alle hier auch so aus meinem Bekanntenkreis, haben damals gesagt, wie alt
war ich denn da, 2000, da war ich 16, ja, ähm, die haben alle so gesagt, oh, das ist doch
geil, also die älteren, ja, die, so, so, das war noch die richtige, also wer 2000 so den
älteren gezählt hat, das war so die richtige Hardcore-Boomer-Generation, ja, die haben
alle gesagt, ja, ist doch geil, dann gibt es endlich richtig Geld, damit kann man Schulden
ausbauen, ja, nur, dass du vom, vom Schuldenabbau kein, kein ordentliches UMTS Netz kriegst.
Das war Hardcore-Boomer, sagen wir mal geht bei euch das Boomer-Emote, wir haben doch
ein Boomer-Emote irgendwo, wenn das bei einer Tastatur nicht umgestellt hätte, ja, haben
wir doch, und das ist meine Ansicht nach eines der großen, äh, Fails gewesen, warum wir
so schlechte, oder warum wir so viele, äh, Lücken haben, was Mobilfunk angeht, ich meine,
ich hab's gestern wieder gesehen, ich bin gestern gefahren von Hanau nach, äh, Frankfurt
Süd und auf so der Höhe von Meintal hast du immer Aussetzer, immer, ich kann mich noch
dran erinnern, im März, ähm, im März ging diese ganze Corona-Homeoffice-Geschichte los
und da war ich gerade auf dem Heimweg, da hat mein Chef eine Einladung geschickt so
nach dem Motto, äh, wichtige Informationen, Krisenstaatbesprechung, so und da stand ich
Frankfurt Süd am Bahnhof, hab mir mein Headset ins Ohr gemacht und hab an der Teamskonferenz
damals teilgenommen, wo es darum ging, dass wir ab jetzt alle erstmal Homeoffice machen
müssen, weil Corona und ich bin im Zug heimgefahren und es ist, ohne Scheiß, es ist alle zwei
Minuten abgeschissen, das ist doch lächerlich und ich hab sogar, ich hab's mir nicht, das
war sogar nur Audio, nur Audio, ja, Max benutzt Teams, ja, was soll ich dann machen, wenn
wir auf der Arbeit Teams verwenden, das ist ja nicht so, dass ich sagen kann, ja, ähm,
also wenn ihr mit mir reden wollt, dann müsst ihr Discord verwenden, ich glaube das funktioniert
nicht so ganz, was ist das denn, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, wo wir gerade beim Thema
Grafikkarten sind, weiß nicht warum ich das aufgemacht hab, in der Schweiz, ja 5G ist
in der Schweiz ziemlich weit vorne, ja, was aber witzig ist, es gibt in der, es gibt
in der Schweiz, dadurch dass die so viel 5G Ausbau haben, auch sehr viele 5G Gegner, die
dann erzählen, dass Gehirn Schäden entstehen und solche Dinge, ok, wahrscheinlich ist
das schlecht, aber, also, ich hab noch kein Residus gesehen, der wirklich schlecht war,
gucken wir uns das jetzt an, ok, das können wir uns danach angucken, ZF-Grizz, wir gucken
uns jetzt eine Runde, ja, zwei Stück oder so an, Moment, ich weiß, dass man, ich glaube
im Ticken lauter kann ich mal, Keck W.
Ja gut, ok, ok, ich verstehe, es ist scheiße für die Leute, die sich eine 2000, wir gucken
ja erstmal fertig, aber da muss ich was zu sagen, nachher,
die ganze Raytracing Sau, die sie durchs Dorf getrieben haben,
na ja, also, Moment,
Naja, also, also, Moment, da, also, so ganz, so ganz stimmt das nicht, wo ich sage.
Also, man sollte sich nicht beschweren, wirklich, wenn man vor zwei Jahren sich eine High-End-Grafikkarte
gekauft hat und es jetzt zwei Jahre später, was für die Hälfte des Preises gibt, was
schneller ist.
Ganz ehrlich, zwei Jahre ist, ist saumissig lang.
Ich weiß, dass das mittlerweile nicht mehr so ist, ich mein, guck mal, ich hab mich ins
letzten Stream doch schon mal drüber aufgeregt.
Ich hab mir vor drei Jahren, ziemlich genau drei Jahren, einen neuen Rechner gekauft.
Oh, hier, da, oktober, also das ist ziemlich genau fast zwei, drei Jahre her.
So, und der Rechner, den ich mir gekauft habe vor drei Jahren, mit 8700k, ein bisschen übertaktet
und 1080ti, gehört immer noch heute, drei Jahre, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, das
gab es doch vor nicht allzu langen Zeiten, gab es das nie, drei Jahre später immer noch
zu den Top 5% der Systeme, so, und das ist absoluter Luxus aktuell, dass man seine Hardware
so lang verwenden kann.
Wenn man sich, wenn man mal zurückguckt, 2000, 2005 auch noch ein bisschen danach,
bis 2010 herum vielleicht, also gerade aber 2000, 2000 bis 2005 herum, da war ein Rechner
nach zwei Jahren, selbst wenn das ein richtig teurer, guter Rechner war, absoluter Shit,
du konntest damit quasi die Sachen auf Low, wenn du Glück hattest, vielleicht starten,
so, und nach drei Jahren war das Ding absolut schrottreif, komplett, also es ist absoluter
Luxus, dass man einen Rechner heute drei Jahre verwenden kann und der immer noch zu
den besten Systemen gehört, also Luxus für Leute, die sich nicht laufen oder Hardware
kaufen wollen.
Ich finde es doof, ich fände es besser, wenn die Entwicklung schneller gehen würde,
dass man sich jetzt nach zwei Jahren aufregen kann, dass es jetzt eine Grafikkarte gibt
für die Hälfte des Preises, die schneller ist, ja, gut, und ja, es gibt Leute, die haben
sich das vor einem Monat gekauft, weil sie nicht wussten, dass was Neues rauskommt, aber
ganz im Ernst, das ist ja nicht das erste Mal so, also wenn man die Sache ein bisschen
verfolgt hat, dann weiß man ungefähr in welchem Abstand was rauskommt.
Und ich würde nie den vollen Preis bezahlen, zwei Jahre nachdem eine Generation rausgekommen
ist, auch wenn die noch nicht das neue angekündigt haben, das ist so bescheuert, also was sie
früher ganz gerne gemacht haben und ich weiß nicht wie es heute ist, die haben meistens
noch die alten Grafikkarten dann recht günstig verkauft, wenn eine neue Generation rausgekommen
ist.
Ich hab mir damals ne, was war das, GTX, GTO oder sowas, das ist schon ewig her, ja sowas,
ich hab mir damals, übrigens witzigerweise waren wir vor 15 Jahren schonmal ungefähr
bei der, bei größeren Zahlen, bei größeren Zahlen als jetzt, da waren wir 7900, so vor
15 Jahren und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, ich hab damals ne 7900 GTO gekauft, weil die
neue Generation rausgekommen ist und das Ding quasi die Hälfte gekostet hat von der GTX,
damals haben wir auch so von 500 Euro oder so geredet.
Halten die Konsolen den Fortschritt nicht krass zurück?
Die Konsolen halten, also wenn überhaupt halten die Konsolen den Fortschritt so weit
zurück, dass die Spieleentwickler gucken, dass der Kram halt gut auf der Konsole laufen
muss und dann vielleicht nicht noch extra Sperenz für den PC einbauen, aber ansonsten
würde ich sagen hält sich das in Grenzen, das wirkt so, das wirkt so, weil sich allgemein
Hardwareleistungstechnisch die letzten 10 Jahre nicht mehr allzu viel tut, das würde
ich nicht unbedingt auf die Konsolen schieben, weil auch CPU-Leistung an sich, wenn du mal
so durch drum herum guckst, was ist überhaupt nichts mit Konsolen zu tun, das ist alles
deutlich langsamer als das früher war.
Was Konsolen machen sind immer so AP Geschichten, X10, X11, X12, was auch immer, so ein bisschen
neun Sperenzchen, das ist so von Konsolengeneration zu Konsolengeneration, aber so allgemein die
Hardwareentwicklung würde ich nicht sagen, auf der anderen Seite ist es sogar eher so,
dass die fette Kohle auf der Konsole verdient wird, immer noch, Ausnahmen bestätigen die
Regel und vieles wäre ohne Konsolen so gar nicht drinnen.
Nein, ne, glaub ich nicht, dass da die Konsolen dran schuld sind, es ist einfach die letzten
10 Jahre, alles langsamer geworden an Hardwareentwicklung, den sollten wir uns jetzt auch noch angucken,
ok.
Können die alle mal die gleiche Lautstärke machen, dass man nicht immer rumstellen muss?
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt, die 1080ti war eigentlich zu schnell, deswegen
hab ich mir auch, also was heißt eigentlich zu schnell, die war zu schnell, dass es jetzt
Upgrade lohnt auf eine 2080 und deswegen, ich hab auch nicht Upgraded, hab ich den Sinn
überhaupt nicht drin gesehen.
Im Prinzip ist es genau der gleiche Inhalt wie das andere.
Wie gesagt, ich finde da muss man sich zwei Jahre später nicht beschweren.
Das ist gesagt.
آ
Du
Da muss man sich nicht beschweren
Ich kann verstehen dass es die leute anpisst wenn sie sich jetzt vor zwei monaten oder so eine
2080 die gekauft haben für 1.800 oder 900 euro oder 1000
Aber
Wenn man wenn man irgendwie sich ein bisschen die letzten jahre das ganze verfolgt hat ist man blöde wenn man zwei jahre später für
Absolut vollpreis sich eine alte generation kauft
Der ist einfach bescheuert ja das das word pc bildvideo war das beste
Das ist das ist beknackt also es ist doch sogar gut ich weiß gar nicht worüber dass ich sie aufregen es ist doch sogar gut
Wenn du jetzt eine grafikkarte kriegst
Für für die hälfte
Weil also finde ich finde ich jetzt echt nicht schlimm
Das das darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen 20 rico das problem ist dass ich die videos auf deutsch nicht lustig finde weil ich sie
Verstehe sie das findet wahrscheinlich leute die spanisch verstehen auch nicht lustig und
Wenn neue amd cpus eigentlich vorgestellt hat das frage ich mich auch genau das frage ich mich auch
Da war ich ja noch drauf also ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt die auswahl ich habe jetzt die auswahl was sinnvolles zu machen
nämlich einfach zu warten bis neue amd cpus und die
verfügbar sind so dass man sie sich kaufen kann ohne irgendwie nachts irgendwelche vorbesteller sachen zu machen
Oder aber ich mache was bescheuertes ich kaufe mir jetzt schon eine 3090
Am 24.9 nacht setze ich mich dahin und spam den den den jetzt vorbestellen button
Und dann baue ich den man aktuellen rechner ein und warte halb bis amd rauskommt
Ich war also das eine wäre sinnvoll und das andere wäre ich will jetzt was neues und geld ausgeben ja ich weiß auch nicht so genau
Warum nicht zf grüß die wollen den graben verkaufen
Zf grüß die wollen den graben verkaufen also
Ich ich
Ich bin mir nicht ganz hier mal gucken mal gucken also wenn amd wirklich das ganze vorstellt jetzt im oktober
Und dann muss ja auch noch eine 4.950 x rauskommen dass ich das lohnt
Oder so mal gucken dann dann ja mal gucken ich weiß es echt nicht
Informatikerlöhne in der schweiz sag mal was dazu können wir machen und bei schweizer schweizer sachen kann man nicht so gut mit deutschern
Geld dran so vergleichen was doch alles viel mehr
Spezialisierte IT verdienen im schnitt
115 das ordentlich das ist exzellent
Dafür kostet der schweiz auch alles mehr
Das ist das ist
Das ist da würde ich einfach am besten wäre es ja wenn man in der schweiz arbeitet und das geld kriegt und in deutschland wohnt
Ja ok was
Das ist ordentlich das ist das das ist mehr als die meisten hier so verdienen
Media matik was ist denn ein mediamatiker
Mediamatiker
IcT was ist ein IcT Operator
IcT supporter die schweizer haben komische wörter was ist das
Okay, okay was würde ich in der schweiz verdienen guck mal hier easy money
Sourcing manager program manager
Trans spells
Wie du auto zu hoch gegangen
so viele wauts da jetzt hochgegangen ja ja ist doch gut also ich würde ich würde das wenn ich
wenn ich könnte würde ich das auch so machen der schweiz gelb also wenn ich in der schweiz
wohne würde wenn ich in der schweiz arbeiten und in deutschland einkaufen optimal und besseres
geht oder kannst du nicht machen doch top exzellent so also was das hier soll ich mir angucken das ist
aber wieder so ein thema wo ich mich wahrscheinlich jetzt drüber auf aufregen würde ja wie polen
bei uns stimmt der masterkrabber also der der kollege da vom von mir aus dresden der
der fährt auch immer das ist aber so der übelste spa fuchs der fährt auch immer nach polen in
supermarkt und so was kauft da da irgendwie wasserflaschen und gedöns ok bitte das zt
alles klar ok wir gucken uns das jetzt an aber wahrscheinlich ist ein thema wo ich erstmal
hier eine runde wo haben wir das passen haben wir da haben wir überhaupt irgendwie so einen
swift rage emote irgendwie sowas haben wir einen aufreg emote müssen wir mal kurz gucken
habe ich einen emote wo man sich jemand aufregt habe ich gar nicht oder
ja schauen wir mal
people rage gucken wir kein usb video was
ach so zum wegen aufregen ja da nee das hatten wir das letzte mal ja erst
vordorf eine 3000 einwohnergemeinde in niedersachsen rund 15 kilometer von braunschweig entfernt in
diesem haus lebt familie biebel laut genug mein was familie biebel sie wirklich familie biebel
und schweig entfernt in diesem haus lebt familie biebel les rng
mensch ärgere dich nicht in 2020 cringe katja biebel und ihre töchter stella und
gina verbringen nachmittage komm das ist der df da kannst nicht erwarten dass man mehr als 720p
f50 kriegt das uno bei biebel ist die freizeitgestaltung zwangsläufig analog ihre
internetverbindung ist zu langsam für online games netflix und co ok also was haben die für
die verbindung dass sie zu langsam für internet spiele ist ich meine ernsthaft spiele brauchen
so gut wie nichts an bandbreite außer man spielt wasser und dann muss man 200 gigabyte
runterladen aber während dem spielen selbst also spiele brauchen keine bandbreite katja biebel
arbeitet für einen großen automobil die heißen ernsthaft biebel oder stelle viele ihre kollegen
sitzen wegen kohlen ping wird nicht bequatscht was der pinger überhaupt nichts mit zu tun
es sei denn was sattelit oder sowas die 52 jährige aber muss jeden tag ins büro excellent
tastatur reich doch also also moment für spielen 2 mbit vollkommen ok für alles andere für den
arsch aber zum spielen reichen 2 mbit absolut keine probleme um home office zu machen und
remod desktop 2 mbit mag auch hinhauen aber es ist nicht schön internet geschwindigkeit
kann keine rede sein die verbindung ist so langsam dass videos nur ruckeln das heute
journal mit marietta slomka dauert mit unterbrechungen fast drei stunden der
grund daten kommen hier über eine alte kupferleitung der telekom ins haus katja
biebel testet die übertragungsrate heute gerade mal 1,1 megabit pro sekunde das lamen netz auch
ein problem für ihre töchter die 17 jährige stella und die 14 jährige gina brauchen das
internet zum lernen als ihre schulen wegen corona online unterrichtet haben waren sie
auch das kriegen sie in deutschland nicht gescheit gebacken mit online unterricht mussten
sie sogar das haus verlassen meistens wenn ich halt eine größig große datei habe zum
runterladen muss ich noch irgendwo anders hinfahren oder so die ultratiefe stimme oder zu
meinen onkel und meiner tante und das ist halt auch mal muss man den fad weg mit einwischen stella und
gina fühlen sich digital abgehängt und dadurch benachteiligt es ist so unfair dass die drei
häuser weiter im neubaugebiet haben glasfaser und wir sind hier und wissen nicht was wir machen
sollen ihr problem ist starlink wobei das mit starlink also der große heilsbringer wird das
nicht so wie jetzt manche da vielleicht hoffen kann ich jetzt schon sagen das wird wahrscheinlich
wird sogar mehr probleme machen als dass es leuten in abgelegenen regionen großartig was
bringt familie bibel wohnt auf der falschen straßenseite 200 meter entfernt ist ein
neubaugebiet hier gibt es glasfaser mit lichtschnellem internet licht schnelles
enthält der datenübertragung in sichtweite und doch unerreichbar für bibles und ihre nachbarn und
genau dagegen wehren sich die einwohner verschiedener ortsteile ihre bürgerinitiative fordert schnelles
internet für alle warum muss es dazu überhaupt eine fucking bürgerinitiative geben die müssen
mal mit ihrem scheiß beikommen dieses thema geht mir so auf den sack egal weiter kritisieren die
gemeinde ist ein digitales flickwerk es gibt zig verschiedene anbieter und zig verschiedene
technologien die jeweils im dorf aufgeteilt sind eikos hat zum beispiel neubaugebiet da gibt
es glasfaser bis zum haus während der alte ortskern entweder richtfunk nutzen muss oder
kupfer richtfunk und das ist in meinen augen eine zweiklassendigitalisierung richtfunk ist richtig
konkret aussieht zeigen sie uns in dieser straße dieser straße liegt zum einen kupferkabel noch
von der telekom plus jetzt komplett neu das glasfaserkabel was dann hier reinschwenkt ins
neubaugebiet aber dann ist doch alles gut wenn sie sagen einfach sein haus umsetzen bereits das
glasfaserkabel ja dann herzlichen glückwunsch dann sind sie ja schon ganz weit vorne hier sind wir
aber im herzen der zweiklassendigitalisierung die leute die hier an der straße wohnen die dürfen
nicht angeschlossen werden nur dieses neubaugebiet mit den 30 häusern hat glasfaser das ist halt
richtig fehl wieder wörtlich in die röhre gucken willkommen in absurdistan bei neubauten sind
glasfaseranschlüsse bis zum haus seit 2016 vorgeschrieben an bestehenden gebäuden darf
das schnelle netz aber vorbeigelegt werden deshalb schließt die telekom auch hier nur das
neubaugebiet an die sind gewappnet für die zukunft die alteilkoster und die redner und
die forderfahrt die sind es nicht und deshalb kämpfen wir für glasfaser bis in die häuser
das ist so unglaublich beknackt darin und bürger unserer gemeinde wir fragen die deutsche telekom
ag warum sie nur diese häuser an das glasfasernetz anschließt ein interview bekommen wir nicht
schriftlich teilt das unternehmen mit in den älteren ortsteilen seien bereits andere
internetanbieter aktiv wörtlich heißt es einen eigenen netzausbau in diesem bereich
plant die deutsche telekom nicht dieser wäre unwirtschaftlich es ist das ist einer meiner
hauptkritikpunkte sei es jetzt was infra generell infrastrukturausbau es sollte nicht drum gehen
auch bei medizinischer versorgung abwasser strassen sonst was es sollte nicht primär
darum gehen dass mit die sachen ultra wirtschaftlich sind sondern dass man eine ordentliche versorgung
für die bevölkerung hat ich meine dass man das ganze anstrebt dass das kostendeckend
es ist vollkommen in ordnung und dass so eine zumindest auf den ersten blick privater laden
wie die telekom kohle machen ist auch ok aber da fehlen einfach die raumbedingungen
der glasfaser ausbau in deutschland ist aufgabe privatwirtschaftlicher unternehmen der staat darf
mit fördermitteln nur dann eingreifen wenn an einem ort zwei dinge zusammenkommen erstens die
internetgeschwindigkeit liegt unter 30 megabit pro sekunde die sogenannte aufgreifschwelle
zweitens kein privates unternehmen plant konkret auf eigene kosten einen ausbau das sogenannte
marktversagen tatsächlich hängt deutschland beim glasfaser ausbau so wie hier ich meine wir
gucken wir sind seit seit zehn jahren seit zehn jahren
regen wir uns allesamt rüber auf wie schlecht das ist und von jahr zu jahr regt man sich weiter
darüber auf wie schlecht das ist aber im prinzip wird an den grundlegenden sachen warum das so
schlecht warum das so schleppend geht überhaupt nichts gemacht das fängt ja schon damit an dass
wenn die wenn wo da vorn bei der einen seite aufgebuddelt hat dass dann manchmal die telekom
ankommt zwei wochen später wieder aufbuddelt oder aber umgedreht die telekom nicht aufbuddeln
darf weil wo es ist komplett bescheuert der sächsischen vordorf deutlich hinterher nur
rund zehn prozent der haushalte hatten 2019 einen glasfaseranschluss verfügbar weit weniger die
soll man nach südkorea gucken was das angeht südkorea ist vielleicht nicht ganz so groß hat
vielleicht nicht ganz so viele einwohner ich glaube so ungefähr ein drittel oder so an einwohner und
fläche aber da funktioniert das wunder wunderbar und bei uns ist das halt bei uns ist das absolut
keck keck keck da reicht tec dabel keck w nicht das ist keck quadruple u ist das
ist das bei uns zum beispiel in italien mit rund 31 prozent frankreich mit sieben südkorea macht
auch über über landleitung ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung im detail wieder südkorea
macht aber es scheint ganz gut zu funktionieren 60 prozent oder spanien mit 86 prozent der internet
alltag vieler bürger steht in krassem widerspruch zu den versprechen der politik schließlich
wollte die bundesregierung bereits bis 2018 alle haushalte mit mindestens 50 megabit pro
sekunde versorgen ja ja das habe ich ja sogar 50 mal retweetet das 10 prozent der leute nein
nein nein südkorea südkorea hat hat 50 millionen einwohner oder so wir haben 80 millionen so ein
großer unterschied ist das nicht das habe ich 20.000 mal immer mal wieder retweetet diese
ankündigung und hat mich darüber lustig gemacht über welche technik man das letztendlich macht
ist ja fast egal das wird das wird den mit die 2 m bit haben auch egal sein mein glasfaser
wäre natürlich prämium da geht in zukunft sogar noch ein bisschen mehr wenn da koachsleitungen
liegen ist es auch ok aber du hast so viele ländliche gebiete wo du wo du wenn du glück
hast matthias light kriegst wenn man sich diese karte hier anguckt die habe ich und die zeige
ich ja gerne gerade im osten wenn du da mal ranzoomst ist ja komplett im arsch
und die au da ist neu die haben den neu gebaut guck mal hier das da sieht jetzt moderner aus
works ist halt der ping scheiße nie warum
was hat das jetzt im ping doch wurscht
also über 50 mit alle technik also wir wollen nicht alle technik wir wollen leitungsgebunden
haben so und gerade und gerade hier im osten also man sieht ja schon allein hier 75 also das
müsste er eigentlich schon mal flächendeck 95 müsste leitungsgebunden 50 mbit plus sollte
eigentlich schon mal 95 prozent plus sein weil ja bis 2018 50 mbit für jeden wissen wir ja
aber gerade wenn man hier mal so im osten ranzoomt und wartet bis das lädt das ist der witz gerade
wenn die hier ein bisschen ländlicher reinguckst ist ja wirklich ganz ganz grausam hier guckt man
mal weiter
der chat ist im weg jetzt zu spät
ist da link wird da auch nichts großartiges dran ändern es gescheitert das neue ziel der
bundesregierung lautet ein gigabit glasfasernetz für deutschland bis 2000 das ist so geil es ist
so geil es interessiert einfach keine sau dass man es verkackt hat also diese diese 50 mbit bis
2018 das ist ja nicht das erste breitband ziel was wir verschissen haben man macht einfach
man macht einfach weiter ohne darauf einzugehen normalerweise müsste man eigentlich sagen ok
warum haben wir dann 50 mbit bis 2018 nicht geschafft und warum haben wir das bis heute
nicht geschafft aber nein das macht man nicht man sagt einfach ja bis 2025 gigabit was ein
was ein scheiß gelaber alle wohl wieder bei dem eigentlichen thema sind wo ich mich das letzte
mal im stream ja irgendwie fast eine stunde darüber ausgelassen ab du kannst dich einfach
nicht darauf verlassen dass irgend einer was für dich macht leider gibt es so sowas so was hier
wo du selbst relativ wenig machen kannst aber in allen bereichen wo du was selbst machen kannst
ist es besser du machst das selbst anstatt sich darauf verlässt dass irgendwann mal ein anderer
was für dich macht ist leider mittlerweile so man muss man muss selbst gucken wo man bleibt es
wäre mir auch lieber wenn es anders wäre aber man kann es ja nicht mich nicht absolut null noch
drauf verlassen es gibt es gibt immer wieder leute die ankommen und sagen ja wenn ihr uns wählt dann
machen wir was ganz tolles für euch und im strich passiert gar nichts egal egal welche farbe es ist
eigentlich vollkommen egal und von 20 aufbauen das wurde auch im koalitionsvertrag so festgeschrieben
der koalitionsvertrag interessiert hat kein glasfaser in jeder region und jeder gemeinde
möglichst direkt bis zum haus bereits in fünf jahren soll also ein glasfasernetz aufgebaut sein
zu dem jeder bürger zugang hat das entspräche 100 prozent der haushalte mitte 2019 hatten
jedoch gerade mal 10,4 prozent der haushalte zugang zu reinen glasfaseranschlüssen da gibt
es noch viel zu tun schach 96 13 monat dankeschön excellent subscription
erreicht die politik diesmal das nein nein mit der dazu muss man doch nicht mal hellseher sein
wir haben nicht einmal nicht eines unserer breitband ziele der letzten frag mich nicht
20 jahre erreicht weiß ich ob es schon so lang gibt ehrlich gesagt wir haben es noch nicht einmal
geschafft warum soll man das bis 2005 uns das ist vor allem jetzt sogar das unrealistischste
von ordneter mitglied im beirat der bundesnetzagentur und beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit fragen der
digitalen infrastruktur die raumbedingungen sind teilweise richtig für völlig unrealistisch wenn
wir mit dem tempo weitermachen würde das noch 100 jahre dauern ja dieses ziel erreichen also ich
glaube das ist eher eine traumtänzer strategie ein grund für den schleppenden breitbandausbau
das förderprogramm der regierung funktioniert nicht sagt krischer insgesamt stehen circa
elf milliarden euro zur verfügung bewilligt für konkrete projekte sind davon gerade mal 6,6
milliarden das hat sogar dazu geführt dass ich früher mal die piratenpartei gewählt habe wegen
dem kram schon vor so vor vor frag mich nicht 15 10 10 jahre oder so als als es die noch gab und mich
außer diesem thema technik sonst nichts interessiert hat ich glaube die gibt es gar nicht mehr
mittlerweile von den habe ich nix mehr gehört erfolgloseste bundesprogramm dass es lange
gegeben hat das geld ist kaum abgeflossen tatsächlich sind seit 2015 nur rund 566
millionen euro ausgezahlt worden das ist ja nix das milliardenschwere förderprogramm hat
einen haken das geld darf nicht eingesetzt werden sobald eine minimalversorgung von 30
megabit pro sekunde vorliegt ja moment wie passt das damit zusammen dass wir 50 mbit für
alle haben wollen bis 2018 schwelle soll zwar auf 100 megabit pro sekunde erhöht werden doch
auch diese übertragungs rate sei lichtjahre von einer gigabit gesellschaft entfernt sagen
experten ganz ehrlich ganz ehrlich gigabit ist mag ja schön und gut sein ehrlich gesagt kaum
jemand also man muss natürlich in zukunft denken aber aktuell ist es so kaum jemand ist hat das
wirklich nötig dass das gigabit sein müsste viel wichtiger wäre eigentlich dass man wirklich mal
so eine so eine so eine annehmbare basis hat sagen wir von meinetwegen sogar 50 mbit ich
wäre eher für 100 mbit wo du dich dann aber auch wirklich darauf verlassen kannst dass du
die kriegst weil was hast du denn davon wenn die jetzt eh schon super ausbau haben irgendwo
mitten in frankfurt oder so wenn die demnächst dann auch noch zusätzlich ein bisschen mehr
gigabit bekommen also sprich die leute die jetzt 400 mbit plus jetzt schon bekommen kriegen dann
halt gigabit ich meine ich habe da kein problem mit ich würde ich würde es ja mittlerweile glaub
bei wundervoll auch kriegen aber wichtig ist dass du doch mal auch guckst dass die jetzt nichts
bekommen die die die bibel leute wenn die 2 mbit haben dass die mal irgendwie eine ordentliche
basis bekommen wo du was machen kannst und man glaubt das gar nicht was korona bewirkt hat hier
so gesellschaftsmäßig jetzt nicht um also gerade durch korona wird diese diese mangel ausbau
erscheinungen die wir da haben jetzt erstmal deutlich aber was das für was das bei vielen
unternehmen und leuten möglich gemacht hat was sie gar nicht für möglich gehalten haben dass
sie jetzt zum beispiel eben von daheim in die schule gehen müssen dass sie von daheim arbeiten
müssen dass sie überhaupt relativ viele sachen machen müssen so wie ist wie sowie also das weil
sie es nicht mehr so machen können wie sie es vorher gemacht haben da sieht man mal was alles
möglich ist und was alles geht in der heutigen zeit schon was man bloß einfach nicht gemacht
hat und dementsprechend fällt jetzt halt besonders stark auf scheiße manche sachen gehen halt mit
unserem steinzeit internet nicht eine 11.000 einwohnergemeinde nicht weit von karlsruhe hier
lebt es sich meist ruhig und beschaulich mit viel sinn für tradition ein heimatmuseum bewahrt die
gute alte zeit etwas zu museal geht es allerdings beim thema breitbandversorgung zu viele bewohner
die wir fragen sind unzufrieden mit ihrer internetverbindung sie bricht einfach ab oder
der fernseher hört dann irgendwann mal auf weil ja keine internet empfangen im internet würden
sich wünschen dass das besser funktioniert dass das gerne aber für gleiche preise ich
bin informatiker ich arbeite in der video bildverarbeitung benachteiligung erleb ich
schon richtig krasser als player ist eine datenmenge mit denen ich arbeite ich im prinzip offline herunterladen muss bedeutet
irgendwelche halbstündige stündige wartezeit bei großen datenmengen natürlich diese probleme
wollte bürgermeister sven weig schon vor jahren lösen 2014 plant er hauptsache für den
louis vitor anzug hat gereicht zu beantragen um hier ein kommunales glasfasernetz zu verlegen
vorher wurden alle netzbetreiber gefragt ob sie in der region eigene ausbaupläne haben
und hatten dann mit der telekom besprochen wollt ihr was was tun zu dem zeitpunkt hat
die telekom gesagt nein wir machen nichts das kann die telekom gut dem landkreis 2014 mit
in diesem zusammenhang werden wir gegebenenfalls auch in dieser region in den kommenden drei
jahren gebiete im eigen ach du scheiße viel mehr relativierung in einem satz geht doch kaum in
diesem zusagen alter was ein satz the fuck was ist das ich habe was gesagt um nichts zu sagen
in diesem zusammenhang werden wir gegebenenfalls auch in dieser region in den kommenden drei jahren
gebiete im eigen ausbau mit breitband erschließen das heißt im endeffekt vielleicht wenn wir lust
haben aber vielleicht auch nicht gegebenenfalls habe ich morgen auch eine millionen abos auf
youtube gegebenenfalls kriege ich jetzt 250 gift subs welchen fall denn gegebenenfalls
gift ich am ende des streams 50 subs an den chat unsere derzeitigen planungen sind aber noch
ja natürlich postchamp eigentlich schon doch keine ahnung wann so lautet die auskunft der
telekom für die gemeinde die daraufhin beginnt ihr eigenes glasfasernetz zu verlegen danach
baut die telekom ihr netz darüber später hat die telekom mit der vectoring technik diesen verteiler
kasten angesteuert und die ganze straße wurde an der seite noch mal aufgemacht bei der modernisierung
des kupfernetzes dem sogenannten vectoring liegen glasfaserkabel nur bis zum verteilerkasten ab dort
werden daten über alte telefonleitungen aus kupfer bis ins haus übertragen vectoring kann
daten mit einer geschwindigkeit bis zu 100 megabit pro sekunde übertragen ein zehntel der
geschwindigkeit des kommunalen glasfasernetzes doch das kann nicht fertiggestellt werden sagt
bürgermeister weigt nur gewerbliche anwohner anbinden alles glasfasern alle anderen privaten
die an dieser dann würde ich sagen einfach ich bin gewerblich manchmal musst du irgendwie den
scheiß austricksen selbst wenn es fragwürdig ist ich meine es reicht wahrscheinlich nicht wenn du
einfach sagst ich bin gewerblich du musst dir dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie was aus den fingern
sagen ich könnte das sagen ja da würde ich einfach mein zettel wo ich die firma angemeldet habe für
die sagen hier bäm gewerblich gut ist aber gut bei den meisten geht es wahrscheinlich nicht
habe ich das richtig verstanden hier liegt also ein glasfaserkabel in der straße du kannst ja
also gewerbe anmelden ich habe mir das auch viel komplexer vorgestellt muss im prinzip
ein zettel ausfüllen abgeben also ist es ganz ehrlich hätte ich die auswahl 2 m bit oder
gewerbliches gigabit da würde ich gewerbe anmelden da mache ich dann mache ich dann
irgendeinen mist auf gut ist wobei ein unterschied gibt du musst glaube ich danach eine steuererklärung
machen vorher ist das ja freiwillig ich glaube danach musst du eine steuererklärung machen
muss übrigens auch wieder demnächst steuererklärung machen das geht mir immer voll auf ich muss die
nicht machen ich habe zum glück steuerberater das macht aber ich muss zeugs zusammensuchen aber
die bürger dürfen nicht angeschlossen werden es ist relativ komplexes förderverfahren es gibt
die sogenannte aufgriffsschwelle das heißt ab wann sagt man politisch gibt es eine unterversorgung
und nur wenn die folgt darf man auch als öffentliche hand eingreifen wenn die nicht folgt darf man
auch nicht ich noch nicht nach den aktuellen förderkriterien das ist doch der witz wieder
hat geschwindigkeit von weniger als 30 megabit pro sekunde daran sieht man doch schon mal den ganzen
widerspruch sie vorne raus wird marketing technisch gelabert 50 mbit für jeden bis 2018 und die
förderbedingungen sind 30 mbit das ist doch absolut krasser widerspruch das ergibt das ergibt überhaupt
keinen sinn als unterversorgung nur wo das der fall ist darf ein glasfasernetz mit öffentlichen
geldern gebaut werden 30 mbit aber erreichen oft auch die alten kupfernetze der telekom so blockieren
vorgaben der politik und vermeintliche geschäftsinteressen der telekom den schnelleren
glasfaserausbau wie in karlsdorf neuthart wir haben die deutsche telekom ag um ein interview
gebeten eine antwort erhalten wir schriftlich das unternehmen widerspricht den aussagen von
bürgermeister weigt wörtlich heißt es die telekom trifft ihre ausbauentscheidungen unabhängig
und anhand von wirtschaftlichen kriterien ein bezug zum glasfaserausbau der kommune ist nicht
im prinzip kann die telekom alles sagen feststanden bevor die gemeinde karlsdorf neuthart eigene
ausbaupläne hatte deswegen hat in die telekom vorher geschrieben dass sie das nicht planen klingt
logisch kommunaler glasfaserausbau mit steuergeldern bezahlt und das wäre eigentlich auch nur option ich
weiß ja ich habe ehrlich gesagt ich kann das nicht abschätzen wie teuer so was ist
ich weiß nicht ob man da irgendwie geld sammeln könnte und und das
und das so finanzieren ich habe keine ahnung ob man ob das realistisch ist
also ich habe ich habe wirklich keine ahnung also mal angenommen
mal angenommen man man würde irgendwie keine ahnung jeder jeder bezahlt 50 euro das reicht
nicht jeder bezahlt 500 euro weiß ja nicht wie groß so eine wie groß so eine gemeinde ist 500
euro was was haben die da für einwohner 10.000 also wenn du 10.000 einwohner hast und jeder hast
du fünf millionen hast du fünf millionen ich glaube da kommst du nicht so weit mit oder ich
habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was das kostet mit richt funken ja das natürlich auch eine
option habe ich da habe ich gar keine ahnung von aber es müssen ja nicht unbedingt glasfaser leitungen
sein ja
und behindert kein einzelfall sagt der bundestagsabgeordnete oliver krischer das
vorgehen der telekom habe system das nennt man überbau das ist eine strategie der telekom die
an ganz ganz vielen ställen stattfindet wo sie ihre marktmacht im grunde genommen nutzt ihre
macht über die vorhandene infrastruktur das kupferkabel um damit am ende den glasfaserausbau zu
verhindern indem sie einfach den neuen wettbewerbern die kunden wegschnappt ja mal ganz davon abgesehen
also er bläme da jetzt ein bisschen die telekom die die telekom gehört zu glaub 30 prozent dem
start also so rein so rein nur auf die telekom zeigen da müsst ihr auch auf euch selbst zeigen ja
also das ist auch die rahmen bedingungen wichtig die telekom kann das nur machen so lange sie das
machen kann während die regierung excellent satz die telekom kann das nur machen so lange
sie es machen kann sollte vielleicht besser sagen die telekom kann das nur machen so lange sie das
machen darf ankündigt berüstet die telekom technik auf die im besten fall 25 prozent dieser
geschwindigkeit leistet wie kann das sein ich habe selber im beirat der bundesnetzagentur erlebt wie
die telekom lobbyarbeit betrieben hat dass dieses kupfernetz weiter als alternative gesehen und
gefördert wird und das ist ja aktuell auch es ist ja auch die einzige alternative in vielen bereichen
die jetzt aktuell direkt verfügbar ist ja aber ob jetzt die letzten meter ins haus kupfer sind
klasse sind oder sonst was ist jetzt unmittelbar man für die zukunft sei es mal dahingestellt für
die zukunft natürlich wäre das beste wenn jeder glasfaser anschluss im haus hätte unmittelbar
ist das nicht verkehrt ja aber da musst du zumindest den den infrastruktur ausbau bis
vors haus so weit betreiben dass du die letzten meter mit kupfer ordentlich überbrücken kann über
brücken kannst und du kannst es ja nicht komplett verteufeln weil ansonsten haben die leute die
auswahl ein gigabit glasfaser oder 2 m bit nichts im endeffekt das kann es ja auch nicht
sein ja wenn man das noch wenn man das noch weiter verwendet ich würde das gar nicht mal
so sehr verteufeln um zu sagen alles kupfer muss weg man sollte das eher als technologie sehen die
jetzt gerade verfügbar ist wo man auch durchaus noch weiter investieren und forschen muss aber
für die zukünftigen sachen ist natürlich klar umso mehr glasfaser umso besser aber
du musst dafür dass du das ordentlich benutzen kannst trotzdem weiter ausbauen total das ist
mit eine zentrale ursache warum es im deutschland mit dem glasfaser ausbau nicht weitergeht
dem vorwurf durch strategischen überbau den glasfaser ausbau zu behindern widerspricht
die telekom das unternehmen schreibt das sind immer wieder gerne verwendete klischees und
geschichten die bei konkretem nachfragen bei denen die diese vorwürfe erheben nicht belegt
werden weiter heißt es allerdings auch hätten sie doch jetzt noch mal den typ fragen sollen
der hätten sie den noch mal gefragt warum warum warum sind die jetzt nicht mit der aussage von
der telekom noch mal zu dem typ gegangen und dann sagt ok die telekom hat das geantwortet
versagen sie dazu die antwort hat mich jetzt wirklich mal interessiert obwohl man versuche
überbau zu vermeiden spreche nichts gegen mehrere infrastrukturen das sieht man in
öbisfelde weferlingen ist das hier ein aufwachen stream oder ein aufwachen stream wir sind alle
schon was das angeht wir sind so was von vogue wie man heute sagt wer wacher kann es ja gar
nicht mehr sein einer kleinstadt in sachsen anhalt ganz anders auch hier überbaut die
telekom ein mit steuergeldern bezahltes kommunales netz einer von über zehn fällen die wir in
wenigen wochen gefunden haben mit 15 millionen vom bund und 17 millionen eigenem geld startete
die stadt den glasfaserausbau im sommer 2020 sind bautrupps unterwegs und schließen die
häuser an das zukunftsfähige gigabit netz an bevor die stadt mit dem glasfaserausbau begonnen
hat wurden wie vorgeschrieben alle telekommunikationsanbieter gefragt ob sie hier eigene pläne für einen
breitbandausbau haben wir haben gefragt der kann das machen es haben sich konkret keine leute
dazu gemeldet keine firmen dazu gemeldet es gab sehr nebulöse willensbekundungen das machen die
wahrscheinlich absichtlich wahrscheinlich das absicht dass man so so was wages erzählt oder
der der wills der wills aber auch wissen wir machen das absichtlich dass man da so was unkonkret
es erzählt dass man sagen kann dass man im nachhinein sagen kann ja wieso wir haben uns doch geäußert
dazu klar wollen wir die uns aber nicht weit genug gingen und daraufhin haben wir gesagt müssen wir
selber waren und genau das passiert hier gerade bis ende 2020 sollen alle haushalte an das schnelle
internet angeschlossen sein doch nun gibt es ein problem vor einigen monaten hat die telekom
begonnen ihr altes netz durch vectoring aufzurüsten dort wo die stadt bereits ihr
glasfasernetz verlegt hat wird nun die straße erneut aufgerissen dabei hätte die telekom die
leerrohre der stadt gegen pachten nutzen können anstatt ihr eigenes netz darüber zu bauen wenn
die telekom bauen will sonst bauen die telekom wird nun zur konkurrenz für das kommunale netz da
kostet ein glasfaseranschluss 49 euro 90 pro monat und bietet dafür eine übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
von 500 megabit pro sekunde die telekom bietet einen vectoring anschluss für 43 euro 82 an mit
einer übertragungsgeschwindigkeit von gerade mal 100 megabit pro sekunde je weniger kunden
glasfaser buchen desto länger dauert es bis die stadt das netz abbezahlt hat dadurch fehlt geld
das an anderer stelle gebraucht wird wir fragen die telekom warum sie in öbisfelde weferlingen ihr
kupfernetz parallel zum glasfaserausbau der stadt erneuert schriftlich teilt das unternehmen mit
man habe die ausbau absichten bereits vor jahren bekannt gegeben doch die stadt hätte die
erforderlichen raugenehmigungen verzögert deswegen kommen da immer so vage aussagen dass man sich
auf sowas zurückziehen kann weiter heißt es im zuge des ausbaus des glasfasernetzes durch die
stadt hätten wir uns eine koordinierung der baumaßnahmen gewünscht die verweigerung mal eine
frage vielleicht vielleicht haben wir irgendwie dass ich ausgenommen mal angenommen ich grabe
jetzt in meiner straße oder in meinem ort alle straßen auf liegt da glasfaser rein schließ
alle häuser an so dann habe ich ja immer noch das problem ich muss mehr ich muss ja irgendwie mich
irgendwo anschließen ja rein glasfaser leitungen die einfach in der straße liegen da kannst du
nicht ins internet so bei der telekom bei wo davon und sonst was ist klar ja die machen das selbst
da muss ich ich muss doch dann irgendwie gucken dass ich dass ich in irgendeiner art und weise zu
zu irgendeiner zu einem etwas größeren knoten punkt noch hinlege meine leitung wo ich mir
anschließen kann oder also irgendwie muss ich ja ans internet kommen
und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen dass so am arsch der welt hier dass es auch bis sie weg
ein bisschen weiter weg ist
ich habe da jetzt habe ich keine großartige in frankfurt ist das kein problem in frankfurt
hast du wo du hinguckst irgendwelche leerrohre wo zeugs drin liegt das läuft also unter dark
fiber oder sowas was jetzt das ist kein kein kein schwarzes licht oder so das sind einfach
glasfaser die da liegen und unbenutzt sind es dann dark fiber
man muss ja irgendwo angebunden werden
leider nicht ermöglicht ein weiteres kapitel aus absurdistan während viele gemeinden in
deutschland auf den breitbandausbau warten wird hier doppelt verlegt statt das ziel der
gigabit gesellschaft gemeinsam zu verfolgen kommt es zwischen kommunen und der telekom immer wieder
zu auseinandersetzungen ein grund liegt in der geschichte der telekom und ihrem wechsel vom
staatsunternehmen zum aktienkonzern ja 1995 aber trotzdem du kannst du kannst das ist ja eigentlich
das was die politik allen bereich machen du kannst es nicht unbedingt selbst direkt machen
ja kann er schlecht irgendwie eine hingehen die schaufel schwingen aber der will kann er das
schon du musst die passenden raumbedingungen für das schaffen wo du willst dass sich das in
diese richtung entwickelt und das war mir halt auch schon seit 20 jahren nicht der deutschen
bundespost drei aktiengesellschaften deutsche post postbank und deutsche telekom ron sommer
vorher chef des konzerns wird vorstandsvorsitzende kann ich noch erinnern 1996 geht die telekom ag an
die börse als aktiengesellschaft muss die telekom wie krass die da damals die leute
gebaited haben mit telekom aktien nicht mehr dem gemeinwohl dienen jetzt heißt der auftrag
geld verdienen und das klappt 2019 macht das unternehmen 3,9 milliarden euro gewinn und das
freut wiederum den bund mit knapp 32 prozent aktienanteilen ist der start größter gesellschaft
der telekom und kassierte allein in den letzten fünf jahren knapp 1,4 milliarden euro dividenden
an der universität duisburg-essen forscht und lehrt professor torsten gerpott seit über 15
jahren im bereich telekommunikationswirtschaft das machen die das machen die in solchen
fernsehbeiträgen muss kurz ein bisschen zurück dem ursprüng im net ins was sie angucken das machen
die gerne intro da lassen sie leute immer einen gang lang laufen und filmen das oder sie sitzen
leute an rechner und die dürfen dann irgendwie ganz ganz interessiert in den bildschirm gucken
und irgendwas auf ihrer tastatur tippen so nach dem motto wir haben ihn bei der arbeit gefilmt
die telekom ist jetzt nicht ein privatwirtschaftliches unternehmen muss
sich nach privatwirtschaftlichen maßstäben orientieren und das kann man hier dann eben
auch nicht vorwerfen und wenn halt eine gemeinde ausbaut dann ist es für die telekom so dass ein
neuer wettbewerber auftritt und von daher finde ich es völlig legitim wenn man eben sagt da
tritt jetzt wettbewerber auf da müssen wir auch was tun sonst gewinnen wir keine kunden
mehr sonst verlieren wir unsere bestandskunden es geht um deutschlands zukunft höchste zeit dass
der politisch versprochene glasfaser irgendwie war der schnitt jetzt ein bisschen bisschen hart
oder der typ hat irgendwas gesagt und jetzt gehts endlich stattfindet
und der beitrag muss fertig werden da war schon zu lang
ja ja passt ja also der beitrag in sich ging ja was 100 betriebssystem von einem usd extrem
multiboot dass irgendjemand gepostet ich soll mir das mal angucken ob das was taugt
gekürzt für youtube normal 30 echt jetzt oder es ist oder es ist ein witz ich kann
mir nämlich echt vorstellen dass das stimmt
ich habe eigentlich so lustig das kann das ist das ist das sind die das sind die mit
dem windows optimierungs pack das kann ich das geht kann ich angucken da sind die mit
diesem komischen windows optimierungs pack wo wir uns machen könnt ihr euch noch dran
erinnern dieses windows optimierungs pack mit powershell mit powershell gui wisst ihr
noch mit powershell gui das powershell gui und wie das programmiert war das war grausam
ok ich kippe ich kippe mal kurz durch ok das ist das ist bestimmt cringe was zum teuer
ist mit der kamera führung ich halte es nicht klappt aber macht ein schnitt alle 20 sekunden
alle alle zwei sekunden ist eine geile idee für die leute die es nicht wissen warum
es ist ja nicht so dass heute noch irgendjemand isos brennen würde oder so ne
also ich glaube meinen letzten vier rechner hatten kein optisches laufwerk mehr ich meine
auch wozu 32 disk image für die auf einem usb ok ne das kann ich mir nicht geben mir
vor recovery im das das geht nicht das kann ich mir nicht angucken das ist der neue youtube
lifestyle jeder neue satz einmal raus und rein zu mehr ich weiß schon das ist wie meine
zeit lang als als als ungenau nicht recht nicht nur reaction videos gemacht hat wo jeder
am anfang mit seiner kamera gemacht hat kann es ja noch einer dran erinnern es gibt so
ein paar youtube sachen die wer ich nicht verstehe sucht doch nach dem programm und
nach dem kerb naja so dinge den nach dem programm muss ich nicht suchen es gibt sich so so multiboot
sachen dass ich das ist ja nicht das einzige so was haben wir jetzt hier noch schönes
wie fix windows 10 mal was ist ok das ist wieder mit ein ziemlich übertriebener titel
ich habe da so meine zweifel dass microsoft sich überhaupt auch nur ansatzweise für
interessieren wird mal gucken mal gucken was was was fixen sie dann wahrscheinlich werfen
sie irgendwelche sachen runter oder so für die meisten leute funktioniert das auch überhaupt
nicht die meisten kacknubs vor allem wenn ihr ein paar spiele spielen wollen ist mit
ninox kommt kommt kommt so weit und das sage ich als jemand der mit ninox ein geld verdient
aber es
Linux, es sei denn, es sei denn du möchtest nur SuperTuxCard spielen.
Hat einer von euch mal VSL2 benutzt? Ja, wenn man keine Linux VM verwenden kann oder will, ist VSL2 tatsächlich nicht
übel. Es laufen 11,5k Games auf Linux, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob das viel oder wenig ist. Wenn ich mir
angucke, wie viel Schrott es auf Steam gibt, da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch Millionen Games und davon ist vielleicht
ein Prozent Spielenswert, sagt die reine Anzahl von was irgendwo irgendwie läuft nicht wirklich viel aus.
Erstens ist die Frage von wie viel und dann ist auch die Frage wie gut, was versteht man unter Laufen und spätestens,
wenn es an die größeren Titel geht, von VR fangen wir mal gar nicht an, aber rein um Multiplayer und das ist ja
nur mal was, was eine riesen Userbase hat und Multiplayer, gar Multiplayer mit Anti-Cheat oder gar
Spiele mit Kopierschutz oder sowas. Da wird es schon arschdünn unter Linux. Wow, ist ja gut, äh.
Ich habe auch nicht gesagt, dass jedes Spiel nicht funktioniert, aber du hast damit Probleme.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es zum Beispiel mittlerweile mit, was nehmen wir mal, keine Ahnung, wie sieht es mit Overwatch aus?
Overwatch Multiplayer, wie gut, dass es mittlerweile noch nicht losgeht.
Wozu brauche ich sowas?
Das Video ist doch übelst laut.
Ja, warum man Windows Updates deaktivieren soll, verstehe ich auch nicht. Ganz viele dieser Guides sagen immer, man soll Windows Updates deaktivieren, aber warum?
Okay, okay, also jetzt mal nur mal von der Logik her. Das heißt, ich finde es doof, was Microsoft macht.
Dementsprechend baue ich es aus und ersetze es durch irgendwas, was noch viel unsicherer ist, oder was?
What the fuck? Also ich traue Microsoft nicht, aber ich traue irgendwelchen random Dudes dann, ich weiß nicht, da bin ich ja immer. Mal gucken, was sie da machen.
Ja, kann ich gleich machen, Official Dark Ice.
Warum? Also okay, ich lasse ihn jetzt erstmal, bevor ich da jetzt wieder rumwecke, aber...
Das stimmt, das stimmt, Windows Mail ist wirklich absoluter Crap. Da war sogar Outlook Express besser und das war schon mal...
Das sieht nicht nach Windows 10 aus, das sieht nach Windows 10 mit irgendwie Custom GUI aus, was versucht nach Windows 10 auszusehen.
Das ist ja, das ist ja, das ist ja ganz, ganz, äh, ja, naja.
Das ist, das ist OpenOffice, oder?
Also, OpenOffice, gehen wir fort. Aber ich hab nicht nur was gegen OpenOffice, ich finde jegliche Office Software ist komplett überflüssig.
Außer die einzige Office Anwendung, die ich für sinnvoll halte und die was bringt ist
Tabellenkalkulation.
Das ist für die Leute, die gerne irgendwelche, so die Datenbank-Bastelumgebung für Leute,
die ich programmieren kann.
Was benutzt du für Office?
Zoll gar nichts.
Ich benutze den Markdown Editor und den HTML Format, das reicht.
Ich mache keine Powerpoint in HTML, ich mache einfach eine PDF, da machst du einen PDF-Reader
im Fullscreen auf und gut ist.
Oh nein, jetzt muss er wieder sein Unterhaus Werbung machen.
Die lange Zahl im Chat, meistens verwende ich tatsächlich Wim, wenn ich was auf der Arbeit
mache.
Ich verwende Markdown nicht zum gleichzeitig formatieren und mir Vorschau angucken, eigentlich
hauptsächlich zum Highlighten von Text, weil es dann besser strukturiert aussieht, aber
man kann es halt zur HTML rendern und sieht dann auch ganz gut aus oder Visual Studio
Code mit Vorschau.
Was?
Moment, was?
Warum?
Was?
Es ist nur eine Vorbereitung, glaube ich.
Aber sie haben es hier benutzt, weil einige von den Veränderungen, die sie mit Windows gemacht haben, auch Explorer verursacht haben.
Also mussten sie Old Explorer benutzen, um es aufzupacken.
Ich kann dir jetzt sagen, dass es nur eine Sache ist, bei der ich mich umsetzen möchte.
Wenn ich etwas suche und in dieses Folder gehe,
wenn ich auf Folder klicken,
du Scheiße, das ist nicht das, was ich will.
Ich will, dass es auf ein Folder geht.
Wenn ich zurückkehren möchte...
Okay, mit dem Problem kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Da verwende ich Windows zu wenig Windows-mäßig dafür.
Ich mache dann einfach, wenn ich irgendwie etwas machen will, in irgendeinem Ordner.
Und dann mache ich einfach hier auf und gehe in den Ordner rein und mache dann was.
Aber ich weiß, das ist nicht der Windows-Weg.
Das macht der normale Windows-User so wahrscheinlich nicht.
Auf ein Folder bedeutet, auf ein Folder in der Direktorenstruktur.
Das sieht so aus, als wäre das Windows 10-Type-Settings-Menü.
Aber hier ist noch weniger Sachen drin.
Was ist mit dem?
Es ist vieles von dem, was mit dem Telemetrie-Stuff geteilt wurde.
Windows-Update, Gaming, das Xbox-Stuff.
Das wurde mit dem Telemetrie-Stuff und dem Telephone-Holm geteilt.
Also, ziemlich vieles, was mit dem qualifizieren würde, würde auch geteilt werden.
Kann ich sogar einen Screensaver aufsetzen?
Ich denke so.
Es ist auf dem Display.
Ist es nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, ist es?
Warte, hier ist es, hier ist es.
Ich habe es, ich habe es.
Also, man kann es nicht suchen.
Ich denke, das würde wahrscheinlich sein, weil sie die regelmäßige Suche auch geteilt haben.
Ja, ohne Cortana würde das Windows-Search einfach sterben.
Ich wusste eigentlich nicht, dass dieser Bubble-Screensaver...
Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass Cortana und Windows-Suche zusammenhängen.
Das ist ein Windows-Vista-Klassiker hier.
Das war so cool damals.
3D-Axzelleration auf dem Desktop.
Der beste, der beste Windows-Bildschirmschoner ist immer noch... Moment, Windows... Alter, ich kann nicht mehr schreiben.
Das XP-Labyrinth. Ja, das geht auch.
Pipes ist der beste.
Oder Maze.
Wobei das schon zu schlecht aussieht aus heutiger Sicht eigentlich.
Ich möchte nur diese Bubbles für wenige Tage schauen.
Wir sind an dieser Stelle über Screensavers geworden als Spezies.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein paar aktuelle Sachen an, wie gut hier unter Linux laufen.
Okay, die Top 10% laufen schon mal gar nicht.
CS läuft. CS ist ja auch ein bisschen Vorzeigeprojekt.
Wo kann man hier suchen?
Suchen wir mal zum Beispiel... Was ist denn jetzt gerade neu?
Horizon Zero... Wie schreibt man das? Ich kann das nicht schreiben.
Gut, schon das erste Game, worin ich suche Sprocken. Perfekt.
Geht gut los.
Stimmt, Fall Guys. Bei Fall Guys könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass das gut läuft.
Platinium. Wahrscheinlich gibt es da sogar eine Native-Linux-Geschichte von, oder?
Ist das Proton? Okay.
Fall Guys ist Native, dann ist klar.
Das erste Laufen wäre merkwürdig.
Aber wie gesagt, das erste, das erste, nachdem ich gesucht habe, war Sprocken.
Super. Was haben wir als nächstes?
Zum Beispiel das Amazon.
Amazon... Wie ist das?
Amazon New World MMO.
Existiert gar nicht mal.
Doch, hier. Proc. Exzellent.
Warzone.
Warzone geht nicht. Modern Warfare.
Wo ist es denn?
2019.
Ach, das ist nicht auf Steam. Sind das nur Sachen, die auf Steam sind?
Stimmt, wenn das Proton-DB ist, dann sind das nur Sachen, die auf Steam sind.
Okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Okay, was ist auf Steam sonst noch rausgekommen?
Dieses neue Warhammer-Dings.
Wie wird's? Wie das hieß?
Okay. Also, gucken wir mal.
Auf.
Also, die Seiten sind ja schon wieder so benutzerfreundlich wie, äh, an Stilungs-Desktop.
Gucken wir mal. Death Stranding könnte man noch gucken, zum Beispiel. Irgendwas Neues.
Aber mir hat's eigentlich schon gereicht, dass Horizon Zero Dawn nicht läuft.
So ist das erste, was mir eingefallen ist, was jetzt neu rauskommt, es geläuft nicht.
Das ist halt das Problem, was du auch als 0.8.15 Linux-User hast.
Dass es einfach nicht geht. Und für dich komplett unerwartet kommt, dass es nicht geht.
Also, wenn du im Vorfeld genau weißt, was du spielen willst und willst nichts anderes spielen,
und du weißt, dass deine Spiele laufen, okay, gar kein Problem.
Aber einfach so 0.8.15 Drop in Replacement ist es schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Auch wenn das viele immer als was anders verkaufen wollen.
Wie sieht's denn mit Overwatch aus? Overwatch soll ja, glaub ich, ganz gut laufen.
Wie läuft Overwatch?
Okay.
Installer is unable to download Battlenaner.
Also 100% gut wird das auch nicht laufen.
Wenn man keine Probleme mit hat, dass man kleine, gerade wenn man competitive Multiplayer-Sachen spielt.
Unspielbar, okay.
Ja, was denn jetzt? Wir haben einmal Leute, die sagen, es ist unspielbar, und einmal Leute, die sagen, es läuft super.
So, was haben wir jetzt? Iron Harvest ist das jetzt irgendwie neue Strategie-Gedöns, ne?
Wie heißt das Iron Harvest? Doch, es hieß so.
Dann suchen wir hier nochmal nach Zero Dawn.
What?
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich will auch gar nicht sagen, dass es irgendwie schlecht wäre, oder dass jemand total bescheuert ist, wenn er die Sachen auf Linie spielt.
Aber man kann sich da nicht drauf verlassen, dass das geht.
Vor allem, wenn du MMOs spielst und Sachen mit Anti-Cheat, da musst du ja quasi, also gerade bei MMOs, da musst du ja bei jedem Content-Patch dir erstmal denken, oh fuck läuft der Kram danach noch.
Das ist einfach nicht für den normalen User, also immer noch nicht für den normalen User geeignet.
Das ist mittlerweile cool, was alles geht.
Aber es ist kein Drop-in-Replacement, wie sich das viele Leute vorstellen.
Ist es einfach nicht. Sieht man ja daran.
Du hast es ja wieder gesehen. Das erste Game, nach was ich gesucht habe, ist...
Max, mach mal den 16-Persönlichkeiten-Test.
Ne, warum?
Ja, okay. War der hier verlinkt?
Ja, komm schick Link. Ich mach den Persönlichkeiten-Test.
16-Persönlichkeiten-Test.
Okay, was ist das?
Naja, anteilmäßig muss man ja auch mal sagen,
hier steht es jetzt auf 80% sind was? Gold plus?
Ne, okay, machen wir mal Native. Native ist klar, da muss man nicht drüber diskutieren, ob die laufen.
So, also, wenn 50% der Games Gold plus laufen
und hier wahrscheinlich auch hauptsächlich Games eingetragen werden,
die zumindest mal starten,
ich glaube da ist die Sache mit, dass
im Anbetracht der Menge der Games fast nichts läuft, gar nicht mal so weit von der Realität weg.
Es läuft zwar von den großen Titeln das eine oder andere ganz brauchbar,
aber darauf verlassen, dass der Kram funktioniert, kannst du dich nicht.
Guck mal, das sind 15.000 Games, das ist ja nichts.
Selbst wenn ich in der Etische spiele, das...
Wir müssen da noch gar nicht großartig drüber diskutieren.
Es ist schön, wenn du deine Sachen da drauf spielen kannst,
aber du kannst dich einfach absolut nicht darauf verlassen und ich würde im Traum nicht dran denken,
und das sage ich, wie gesagt, als jemand, der ziemlich pro Linux ist und mit Linux auch sein Geld verdient,
ich würde im Traum nicht daran denken, das als meine Hauptplattform zu verwenden,
wenn eines meiner Hauptanwendungszwecke Spiele wären, würde ich nicht machen.
Ja, wenn das die Games sind, die man spielt, wenn man sagt, okay, ich spiele zum größten Teil CS und Dota
und sonst fast nichts, auch von den Sachen, die neu rauskommen, fast nichts.
Okay, warum nicht?
So, take the test.
Was?
Slash.de.
Was soll...
Okay.
Erhalte eine genaue Beschreibung davon, wer du bist und warum du Dinge auf die Art und Weise...
Aha.
Warum schreibst du immer eine 1?
Oh, das habe ich mal erklärt.
Guck mal, da haben wir sogar ein extra Command für.
Okay, mache den Test.
Du sollst weniger als 12 Minuten auf dem Programm beantworten.
Beantwort die Fragen ehrlich, auch wenn dir die Antwort nicht gefallen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das live streamen machen soll, je nachdem, was da für Fragen kommen.
Okay, versuche, keine neutralen Antworten zu hinterlassen.
Okay.
Ja, man kann die Musik mal dudeln lassen.
Also, es fällt ihnen schwer, sich anderen Menschen vorzustellen.
Was?
Es fällt mir schwer, sich andere...
Hä?
Meinen die mit Vorstellungen so, hallo, ich bin der Max?
Oder meinen die, es fällt mir schwer, dass ich mir andere Menschen vorstellen kann
und das ist bloß nicht richtig geschrieben.
Das erste.
Okay.
Ich mag andere Menschen nicht.
Also, ich...
Also, was ich überhaupt nicht...
Es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Was ich überhaupt nicht mag, sind Vorstellungsrunden auf irgendwelchen...
Schulungen oder so.
Letztens, wo ich diese Microsoft Azure-Schulung hatte, bin ich irgendwie reingekommen,
fünf Minuten zu spät, weil es nicht funktioniert hat in Teams.
Und auf einmal höre ich, wir stellen uns jetzt einmal alle vor.
Fingersaug, Fingersaug, Fingersaug.
Also, ich würde sagen, mittlerweile geht es.
Früher habe ich das extrem ungern gemacht,
weil ich mir da immer so Sachen aus den Fingern saugen musste.
Mittlerweile geht es eigentlich.
So.
Sie verlieren sich oft so sehr in Gedanken,
dass sie ihre Umgebung ignorieren oder vergessen.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Also, na gut, ich bin halt, wenn ich was mache, gerade in Gedanken nicht.
Weil, wenn ich am Rechner sitze und irgendwie was programmiere und mache,
dann, klar, dann vergesse ich, was drumherum ist.
Sie versuchen, ihre Mails möglichst zeitnah zu beantworten
und können einen unordentlichen Post...
Mein Posteingang ist mir vollkommen egal.
Und außerdem ignoriere ich die meisten Mails,
weil ich keinen Bock habe, darauf zu antworten.
Jetzt auf der Arbeit vielleicht nicht, aber privat schon.
Ich kriege tatsächlich noch ab und zu Mails.
Ich meine, guckt euch meinen Desktop an.
Sieht das so aus, als hätte ich irgendwie ein Problem
mit einem unordentlichen Posteingang?
Es fällt Ihnen leicht, entspannt und fokussiert zu bleiben,
selbst wenn Sie ein wenig unter Druck stehen.
Ja, also ein wenig mag ich eigentlich sogar.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Es ist ein bisschen so wie...
So ein bisschen wie im Stream.
Wenn man im Livestream ist und einem die Leute zugucken,
kann man nicht so entspannt denken, wie wenn man...
Wie wenn man jetzt quasi allein vorm Rechner sitzt.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe gern so ein bisschen Anspannung,
mag ich eigentlich ganz gern, weil es mir dabei hilft,
nicht so sehr sidetracked zu werden.
Und ihr kennt mich im Stream.
Ich mache schon auch öfters mal...
Dinger, die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen,
wie effizient ich manchmal Sachen mache.
Also, ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut.
So ein bisschen, ein bisschen Anspannung.
Viel ist für eine Art, aber ein bisschen finde ich ganz gut.
Normalerweise beginnen sie keine Gespräche.
Sie tun selten etwas, nur aus purer Neugier.
Kommt auf den Bereich an.
Also, die meisten Sachen, auch hier dieses ganze Microcontroller,
Programmierzeug mache ich, nur weil ich neugierig drauf bin.
Nicht, weil es da irgendwas bringt.
Also, ich bin halt meistens auf die Sachen neugierig,
die mich auch interessieren.
Und dann mache ich sie auch.
Was ich jetzt nicht machen würde, ist,
ich gehe mal eine Runde klettern oder so.
Was soll ich da drauf sagen?
Also, ich bin halt meistens auf die Sachen neugierig,
die mich auch interessieren.
Also, ich gehe mal eine Runde klettern oder so.
Was soll ich da drauf sagen?
Sie tun selten etwas, nur aus purer Neugier.
Keine Ahnung.
Sie fühlen sich anderen Menschen überlegen.
Das ist okay.
Das ist eine fiese Frage.
Also, ich bin der festen Überzeugung,
dass 90% der Leute in dem, was sie machen, schlecht sind.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich unbedingt das besser könnte.
Aber ich glaube zumindest, dass die Sachen,
von denen ich glaube, dass ich sie kann,
dass ich die auch wirklich ganz gut kann.
Im Vergleich zu dem 0-15-Durchschnitt Lowbob.
Dafür weiß ich aber auch, dass es genug Sachen gibt,
vor denen ich absolut keinen Plan habe.
Ja, so ein bisschen schon.
Aber nur in manchen Bereichen.
Ich weiß halt in vielen Bereichen, dass ich kacke bin.
Da halt nicht.
Organisiert zu sein, ist Ihnen wichtiger,
als anpassungsfähig zu sein.
Vorbereitung ist wichtig.
Aber mit organisiert, also Ordnung, meine ich damit nicht.
Vorbereitet sein ist wichtig.
Also, vorbereitet sein ist wichtig.
Also, zum Beispiel, wenn ich weiß, sagen wir mal,
morgen kommt irgendwie ein Vorstandstyp zum Besichtigen oder so.
Dann überlege ich mir im Vorfeld schon,
was für eine diplomatische, unverfängliche Antwort
auf irgendeine Smalltalk-Frage kannst du dem geben.
Du musst das wörtlich nehmen.
Organisiert in Form von ordentlich, dann...
Keine Ahnung, das ist echt scheiße.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Organisiert zu sein, ist...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, kein Schimmer.
Sie sind für gewöhnlich...
Nein.
Hochmotiviert bin ich selten.
Es ist Ihnen wichtiger, dass niemand verärgert wird,
als dass Sie eine Debatte geben.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Also, ich versuche die meisten Sachen wirklich
so diplomatisch, wie es geht, zu handhaben.
Und mir ist es lieber,
ich habe am Ende zwar vielleicht Recht aus meiner Sicht.
Also, ich weiß, dass ich Recht habe
oder dass der andere was auch immer.
Aber mir ist es lieber,
ich lasse dann sogar dem anderen das letzte Wort,
dass beide Seiten irgendwie den Eindruck haben,
okay, das hat sich gelohnt.
Ja, doch, tatsächlich.
Sie haben oft das Gefühl,
dass sie sich gegenüber anderen rechtfertigen müssen.
Ja, ich erkläre ganz gern, warum ich Sachen mache.
Vor allem bei Sachen, wo ich denke,
dass sie eben...
Dass man erst mal gar nicht versteht,
warum ich sie so gemacht habe.
Aber es hat ja seinen Grund.
Stimmt schon, stimmt schon.
Ihre Umgebung daheim und am Arbeitsplatz
ist ziemlich ordentlich.
Nein.
So ordentlich wie notwendig.
Ich habe mein Werkzeug letztens in ein paar Schränke sortiert,
aber das war es noch.
Es macht ihr nichts aus,
im Mittelpunkt der Aufmerksamkeit zu stehen.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Also, ich habe nichts dagegen,
wenn irgendwie einer was toll findet,
was ich gemacht habe.
Das ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay, sie halten sich eher für praktisch veranlagt als kreativ.
Beides.
Also, ich glaube, in manchen Bereichen,
gerade wenn man Problemlösungen und sowas,
glaube ich schon, dass ich da recht kreativ bin.
Aber ich interessiere mich auch für so Maker-Kram.
Also, schwierig.
Ich würde auch sagen, eher in der Mitte, ja.
Ich bastel gerne, aber ich brauche keine...
Also, es ist schwierig.
Andere schaffen es selten, sie zu verärgern.
Also, ja.
Das stimmt.
Aber wenn mich jemand ärgert,
dann ärgert mich das richtig.
Ja, genau.
Zum Beispiel, die Bahn regt mich öfters auf.
Aber wenn die mich aufregt, dann so.
Nee, ich reg mich schon öfters mal auf, ja.
In Anbetracht der Menge, was mich aufregen könnte,
glaube ich, reg ich mich in letzter Zeit doch nicht mal auf.
Aber insgesamt regt mich schon einiges, ja.
Ihre Reisepläne sind normalerweise gut durchgedacht, ja.
Es fällt ihnen oft schwer,
die Gefühle von anderen nachzuempfinden.
Nö, ich kann mir das eigentlich meistens ganz gut vorstellen,
was bei anderen Leuten los ist.
Ihre Stimmung kann sich sehr schnell ändern.
Nö.
So, weil es sollten die Wahrheit wichtiger sein
als die Wundenpunkte anderer.
Ja.
Sie sorgen sich selten,
wie sich ihre Taten auf andere auswirken.
Ja.
Also, wie gesagt, das passt tatsächlich.
Wenn ich mit anderen über Sachen diskutiere,
dann möchte ich, dass keine der Seiten am Ende das Gefühl hat,
man sind die anderen Spasten oder umgedreht irgendwie,
mit dem rede ich nie wieder oder so.
Was ist das nicht?
Aber ansonsten, so alle anderen Sachen,
ist mir erst mal das Wichtigste,
dass es den Leuten, also mir und den Leuten,
die mir wichtig sind, für die was Vorteilhaftes ist.
Und wenn es dann irgendwie auf Person X, Y,
zu dem ich keinen Bezug hab und die mir am Arsch vorbeigeht,
vielleicht negative Auswirkungen hat,
ist mir das ziemlich egal.
So.
Ihre Arbeitsweise ähnelt eher willkürlichen Energieschümen
als einen methodischen Organ...
Ja, ja, vielleicht eher, ja.
Sie sind oft neidisch auf andere.
Hm.
Oft neidisch auf andere.
Ein bisschen vielleicht, aber oft.
Oft nicht.
Also, manche Sachen gehen mir auf den Kicks.
Also, ich seh...
Sag mal, neidisch eher nicht.
Einige Möglichkeiten, die wir haben,
die ich nicht gut finde, aber das hat ja mit neidisch nichts zu tun.
Nö, eigentlich nicht.
Ein interessantes Buch oder ein Videospiel
ist oft besser als eine paar.
Ja, unbedingt.
Buch weniger, aber Spiel.
Bevor ich mich auf ne Party geh,
da spiel ich lieber zum 20-mal Half Life durch.
Die Fähigkeit, einen Plan zu entwickeln
und dabei zu bleiben,
ist der wichtigste Teil von jedem Projekt.
Wenn es...
Na ja.
Man sollte den Plan haben.
Was stimmt nicht, musst du ankreuzen?
Was denn? Bei was?
Ja, dann so rum, ein wenig.
Äh, ja, wahrscheinlich.
So.
Also, einen Plan zu entwickeln,
da fehlen ja die meisten schon,
einen ordentlichen Plan zu entwickeln.
Dabei zu bleiben, nicht.
Also, man sollte schon ne gute Vorstellung haben
von dem, was man machen will und was eigentlich die Ziele sind.
Wenn sich allerdings rausstellt,
dass man irgendwas
total verkackt hat,
dann...
Aber ein Plan
ist schon wichtig, ja.
Sie verlieren
sich selten in Tagtäumereien und Gedanken.
Ich bin, wenn ich was mache,
fokussiert, aber ansonsten
sitze ich selten rum
und denke darüber nach, ob jetzt
irgendwie...
...grün wirklich grün ist, ja.
Natur! Ha! Lull!
Welche Natur?
Wenn jemand nicht schnell auf ihre E-Mails
antwortet, machen sie sich Sorgen.
Äh, nein.
Ähm...
Als Elternteil wäre es Ihnen wichtiger,
dass Ihr Kind freundlich wird als intelligent.
Nö.
Big Brain.
Beste.
Huge IQ.
Was Sie erlauben, anderen Menschen nicht
ihre Taten zu beeinflussen. Wie soll das überhaupt funktionieren?
Du kannst andere Leute nicht davon...
Du kannst andere Leute nicht davon abhalten,
irgendwie Einfluss auf dich zu nehmen
oder irgendwas zu machen, was
dir in den Weg kommt.
Ach so, die meinen, ob ich
auf andere höre.
Ah, weniger.
Weniger.
Also...
Die Sache ist die,
wenn ich Sachen mache, dann sind die oftmals
aus meiner Sicht
ziemlich detailliert durchdacht.
Und...
Wenn dann Leute kommen und sagen was dazu,
dann passt das oftmals nicht
zu meinen Vorstellungen.
Deswegen höre ich mir das vielleicht an,
aber mach's dann nicht.
Weil ich meinen Plan
für sinnvoller halte, weil ich im Vorfeld
schon mir überlegt hab.
Ihre Träume konzentrieren sich mehr auf die reale Welt
und deren
E-
Ereignisse.
Eine Träume!
Meinen die jetzt, was ich mir wünsche?
Oder meinen die, was ich wirklich... Also die
meinen das, was ich nachts träume.
Okay.
Ich hab letztens was von KegW geträumt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was, ich kann mich
nur noch an das E-Mode erinnern.
Ich hab letztens was von KegW geträumt.
Achso, sie erlauben anderen Menschen
nicht ihre Taten zu beeinflussen. Ahja.
Okay.
Ja, ist der Twitch-Chat real?
Chat.
Ist der Twitch-Chat real?
Das ist schwierig zu beantworten.
Ihre Träume konzentrieren sich
mehr auf die reale.
Kann ich so als nichts zu sagen.
An einem neuen Arbeitsplatz
machen sie sich schnell bei Gesellschaft...
Nein.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Sie improvisieren
lieber als sorgsam zu planen. Nein.
Ihre Emotionen
steuern sie mehr als, dass sie
diese steuern.
Niemals schneller gewählt.
Weiß ich nicht. Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ja, weiß keiner, weiß ich nicht.
Muss er weitermachen.
Ob du emotional... Ich kann das echt schlecht
einschätzen.
Vielleicht, weil ich das schlecht
einschätzen kann, ist sogar
eher das hier.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie gehen gern zu gesellschaftlichen
Veranstaltungen, bei denen man sich nicht...
Bei denen man sich verkleidet. Nein.
Gehst du weg?
Nein.
Gesellschaftliche Veranstaltungen.
So Fasching oder sowas
ist das. Verkleidet.
Rollenspiele.
Sie verbringen häufiger Zeit
damit unrealistische und unpraktische
Ideen zu überdenken, die
jedoch faszinieren. Das stimmt, ja.
Ja, das stimmt.
Viele Sachen, also auch viele Projekte
und so, die sind nicht unbedingt so sinnvoll,
aber die sind interessant. Das stimmt, ja.
Ich habe auch schon viele, viele Sachen
mir hier angeguckt, einfach weil ich es recht
spannend finde,
wo ich weiß, dass da nie was
Volles bei rumkommt.
Nein, das stimmt.
Plan, Plan ist...
Plan ist...
Ja, wobei...
Ich weiß, das klingt merkwürdig und das passt überhaupt nicht.
Auf der einen Seite habe ich gesagt,
bei mir ist die Sache unordentlich und nicht
organisiert, aber ich habe, bevor ich
Sachen mache, wenn ich denn Sachen mache,
habe ich gerne einen Plan, weil ich will,
dass ich möglichst schnell und effektiv
damit fertig bin,
dass ich mich wieder anderen Sachen widmen kann, ja.
Deswegen sage ich ja, dass faule Leute
die besten Ergebnisse haben,
weil sie versuchen, die Sachen
möglichst effektiv und möglichst
so zu machen, dass sie sich danach nicht mehr beschäftigen müssen.
Okay, weiter.
Ja, ja, tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich, ich will eigentlich eher
meine Ruhe, außer mit Leuten,
die ich, außer Leute, die ich mag, ja.
Also den Twitch Chat, der Twitch Chat
ist natürlich, den Twitch Chat mag ich, ja.
Wo haben wir den passenden?
Wenn Sie ein Unternehmen hätten, würde es Ihnen
schwer fallen, loyale Mitarbeiter zu entlassen,
die allerdings geringe.
Tja.
Ich weiß, dass ich so ein bisschen,
dass ich, ich bin, ich bin da ziemlich, ziemlich.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich bin nicht, ich bin
gestört, ja, weil
auf der einen Seite, ja.
Also auf der einen Seite denke
ich, ja, also
zu Leute, die ich einen persönlichen Bezug
habe und die da zuhalten
und so, die würde ich ungern entlassen.
Auf der anderen Seite f**ken mich Leute
übelst ab, die nichts machen.
Genau, genau.
So geht es mir nämlich auch.
Wir hatten beispielsweise auf der Arbeit
einen, der war extrem
nett. Der hat auch immer,
also bei uns im Team, der hat
auch immer
Süßkram verteilt und
hat auf Meetings mitgebracht.
Also ich mochte den Kerl wirklich.
So. Und auf der einen Seite
finde ich es wirklich schade, dass der weg ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen,
er hat halt wenig gemacht.
Ich finde es wirklich schade, dass der weg ist.
Also ich mag den wirklich, aber
auf der anderen Seite hat er mich öfters mal
extrem genervt,
weil er Sachen einfach nicht gemacht hat.
Ja, so.
Ich kann es halt nicht ab
auf Dauer, wenn die Leute
nach fünfmal sagen, die Sachen immer noch
nicht machen.
Sie machen sich oft Gedanken
über den Grund der menschlichen Existenz.
Über das große Ganze
mache ich mir schon Gedanken, ja.
Logik ist normalerweise
wichtiger als Herz, Bauchgefühl,
eine wichtige Entscheidung. Ja, ja, tatsächlich.
Auch wenn es
einen manchmal überkommt.
einen manchmal überkommt, aber
wenn man mal
sich dann einen Tag darüber Gedanken
gemacht hat, kommt man oftmals zu ganz
anderen Entscheidungen.
Also ich weiß, dass Logik wichtiger ist,
auch wenn ich
manchmal mich selbst nicht dran halte, aber wer macht das schon?
Ihnen ist es wichtiger,
flexibel zu bleiben, als Aufgabenlisten
zu arbeiten.
Kommt drauf an,
was auf den Listen drauf steht.
Wenn ihr Freund, ihre Freundin...
Mädchen,
was ist...
Die Frage, die kann ich nicht beantworten.
Wenn ihre Freundin, ihre Freundin
über etwas traurig ist, dann bieten sie
wahrscheinlich eher emotional Unterstützung
an, als dass sie die Möglichkeiten zur Problemlösung
vorschlagen.
Oh, das kann ich schlecht einschätzen.
Ganz eilig?
Beides?
Also ehrlich gesagt,
versuche ich meistens
irgendwie halbwegs zu verstehen, also
wenn ich mich mal doch mal mit
Emotionen anderer Leute da auseinandersetze
und das müssen ja Leute sein, die ich mag,
dann versuche ich mich schon rein
zu versetzen, was das Problem
ist, aber ich versuche dann auch
meistens auf irgendwie
sinnvolle
Lösungen zu kommen, kann ich nicht sagen.
Sie fühlen sich selten
unsicher.
Kommt drauf an. Oh, das ist scheiße
zu beantworten, weil...
Wenn das was ist,
wo ich weiß, dass ich mich
auskenne, dann ja.
Wenn das was ist, wo ich
weiß, dass ich keine Ahnung habe,
dann schon.
Ich tendiere
eher zu nein,
weil ich weiß, dass es deutlich mehr
Sachen gibt, wo ich planlos bin, als Sachen,
wo ich mich auskenne.
Sie haben keine Probleme damit einen
persönlichen Zeitplan festzulegen.
Ich mache nur das Wichtigste
zur Deadliner.
Also auch, also
komplett real life. So eine Steuererklärung
wird immer am 30. Dezember abgegeben,
so nach dem Motto.
Recht zu haben ist bei der Teamarbeit wichtiger
als kooperativ zu sein.
Das Problem bei Teamarbeit ist,
wenn man, mal angenommen,
man ist wirklich davon überzeugt, Recht zu haben.
Und man macht nur die Sachen,
um sie dem anderen Recht zu machen, ist auch
durf. Auf der anderen Seite mag ich es nicht,
wenn man
Sachen durchdrückt
und alle
Scheiße finden.
Das ist auch schwierig zu sagen.
Sie sind der Ansicht, dass alle Meinungen
respektiert werden sollen und nicht
und zwar unabhängig davon, ob diese von
Fakten unterstützt werden oder nicht.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Wenn einer seine Meinung sagt,
soll er das machen.
Ich werde sie wahrscheinlich,
wenn sie nicht gut begründet ist, ziemlich bescheuert finden.
Aber der darf ruhig
seine Meinung sagen. Das ist okay.
Ich finde es zwar total beknackt, wahrscheinlich,
was er sagt.
Also wenn mir jetzt zum Beispiel einer ankommt mit flacher
Erde oder sonst was.
Da bin ich schon dafür, dass der sich öffentlich
äußern darf dazu, dass der
was so sieht und
der sollte da auch keine Probleme durchbekommen. Aber ich finde es
bescheuert.
Mach mal so, vielleicht nicht ganz so.
Sie haben mehr Energie, nachdem
sie Zeit mit einer Gruppe von Leuten
verbracht haben.
Eigentlich bin ich danach müde.
Anstrengend. Andere Leute.
Sie verlegen
Das stimmt.
Respektieren
und sich äußern sind unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Na ja,
die meinen damit schon, dass man
ihn jetzt nicht
irgendwie dafür direkt schlecht
machen müsste.
Das ist schwierig, keine Ahnung.
Wir sind da gleich fertig.
Stufen sich selbst als emotional
sehr stabil ein.
Ja, normalerweise schon.
Das liegt aber daran,
weil mir die meisten Sachen auf der
Welt komplett am Arsch vorbei gehen.
Sachen, die mich persönlich betreffen,
wie zum Beispiel als meine Katze gestorben ist, das
nicht.
Also mir gehen halt 99
Prozent der Welt am Arsch vorbei mittlerweile.
Deswegen ja, deswegen juckt mich das überhaupt
nicht.
Ihr Kopf ist stets voll
voller unerforscht
Ideen.
Das ist richtig.
Zwar sehr spezifische Ideen.
Jetzt nicht sonderlich breit
gefächert. Also es ist nicht so leicht Sache,
ich könnte mal nach Afrika fahren oder so.
Aber ich habe 20.000 Projekte,
auch teilweise unvollendet. Ihr guckt euch mal
ein GitHub Repo an.
Sie würden sich selbst nicht als
Also ich mache die meisten Sachen schon mit
Identitätsbezug. Guckt, dass das irgendwas ist,
was man realistisch machen kann, weil
Sachen, die komplett
unrealistisch umzusetzen sind,
vielleicht ist es manchmal besser, man macht
von den tausend Sachen, die man im Kopf hat, Sachen, die
wenn man wirklich dann was macht,
die man auch
verwirklichen kann.
Es fällt ihnen gewöhnlich schwer,
sich zu entspannen, wenn
sie vor vielen Menschen sprechen.
Ich muss sagen,
ehrlich gesagt, das ist viel besser
geworden.
Das ist viel besser geworden.
Ich habe früher, gerade in der Schule,
weil es auch irgendwie nicht zu mir
passt,
auch zu den anderen Sachen,
ich habe es absolut nicht gemocht,
irgendwelche Präsentation zu halten.
Bis ich irgendwann
festgestellt habe,
dass mir das Spaß macht.
Warum ich das
immer schlecht fand, lag daran,
weil es eigentlich so
meiner,
eigentlich widerspricht das so meiner Natur
mit großen Menschenansammlungen.
Deswegen mochte ich das nie
ursprünglich, so vor innerer
Bauchgefühl
präsentation zu halten, aber
auf der anderen Seite
mag ich das, wenn andere Leute
das geil finden, was ich sage.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen
Konflikt.
Deswegen habe ich mich früher auch
schulmäßig,
weil ich es
von meiner inneren Einstellung her nicht mochte
mit vielen Leuten,
habe ich mich immer
nicht richtig auf die Präsentation
vorbereitet.
Und dementsprechend
liefen die dann auch scheiße.
Aber irgendwann habe ich mal gemerkt,
dass das eigentlich eine richtig
coole Sache ist.
Also, ich erzähle
eigentlich gerne Sachen,
von denen ich mich auskenne.
Stell dir vor, du würdest jetzt vor 250
Leuten echt labern.
Na gut, da würde ich vielleicht nicht Poggers
und Keg W und sowas sagen,
aber
ich habe mich ja mittlerweile sogar schon auf der Arbeit
so Sachen gemeldet, wo man am Ende
was präsentieren muss.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie einfach nur
vor drei Leuten,
sondern erstens
von bis zu Vorstand und dann auch
den ganzen Tag über
immer wieder vor Krüppchen
aus 20 Leuten. Also mittlerweile macht
mir das tatsächlich Spaß.
Und das liegt daran, weil ich festgestellt
habe, wenn man gut vorbereitet ist
auf so eine Präsentation. Und gut vorbereitet
sein heißt halt auch, man muss das
vorher ein paar Mal
geübt haben. Also sprich
ich bin nie mal
ich komme mit Notizen nicht klar.
Also ich kann nicht
ich kann nicht da stehen
bei einer Präsentation und
mich von meinen Notizen irgendwie
leiten lassen. Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich brauche genau Vorstellungen
davon
was ich
bei welchem Bild und sowas ich da
habe.
Also nichts
einstudiertes, sondern einfach, dass
wenn ich quasi dann
irgendwie eine Seite weiter mache,
dann habe ich genau im Kopf
ah ja stimmt, das ist die Seite
wo es das und das zu erzählen gibt. Ohne
Notizen. Deswegen mache ich so eine Präsentation
meistens. Also
ich schaue, dass man meistens schon eins, zwei Wochen
vorher soweit fertig ist. Und dann mache ich
die immer noch mit ein paar Leuten zusammen.
Im Vorfeld ein paar Mal.
Da merkt man auch, dass man sich immer mehr
Standard Sprüche zu den passenden
Folien, zu den passenden
Ereignissen merkt und auch zu den passenden Fragen
die von den Leuten kommen. Da hat man dann so ein paar
Standard Sprüche schon davor.
Einer meiner Lieblingsredewendungen
ist. Und was man auch nicht
vergessen darf. Das sage ich immer.
Immer wenn ich keine Ahnung habe.
Was ich jetzt konkret darauf sage
sage ich, ah ja das ist gut. Aber was
man auch nicht vergessen darf ist das und das.
Ich weiß nicht ob euch das
schon mal aufgefallen ist. Das sage ich echt gerne.
Was man auch nicht vergessen darf
ist folgendes.
Also mittlerweile mache ich das tatsächlich
mache ich das wirklich echt gern.
Irgendwelche Sachen präsentieren
und vorstellen.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen, mittlerweile
macht mir das richtig Spaß.
Und mir macht es
mittlerweile so viel Spaß,
dass ich sogar anfange
mich auf Sachen
zu konzentrieren. Und das ist ja
eigentlich was was nicht so typisch ist bei mir.
Die nicht rein
inhaltlich sind. Sondern mir
auch sogar überlege, so Sachen wie
was für eine Geste könnte man
jetzt machen oder
auf welcher
Seite vom
Fernseher, wenn du
Fernseher oder vom
Anzeigerät stelle ich mich jetzt
bei dieser Sache.
Also ich versuche jetzt sogar mittlerweile
die Sache nicht nur inhaltlich
gut rüber zu bringen, sondern dass das auch noch
einen guten Gesamteindruck macht.
Mein Ziel ist eigentlich, dass die Leute
sich das ganze inhaltlich
gefällt und dass die
von Anfang an
interessiert sind und sich nicht langweilen.
Also mittlerweile macht mir das wirklich
Spaß.
Im Allgemeinen verlasse
sie sich eher auf ihre Erfahrung als auf ihre
Arbeit. Also wenn ich Sachen
mache, dann am liebsten wo ich mich auskenne.
Sie sorgen sich zu viel, was
andere Leute denken. Ja ich sage ja immer, dass man
das nicht machen sollte. Aber
ich muss sagen,
ich mache es immer noch zu viel.
Alter, fertig. Ne, wie? Nicht fertig?
Alter, wie lang dauert das? 12 Minuten?
So, in einem vollen
Raum bleiben sie näher an der Wand und
meinen die Raummitte. Ja,
aber das ist normal.
Das ist normal. Also die meisten Leute,
wenn ihnen unbekannt angenommen,
man geht in ein Restaurant, wo man noch nicht gewesen ist,
man setzt sich immer an die Wand gegenüber
von der Tür.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das schon mal aufgefallen ist.
Wenn ihr irgendwo reingeht, wo ihr neu seid,
ihr setzt euch mit dem Rücken an die Wand, mit dem
Blick zur Tür. Das ist ganz normal.
Was, wenn man
ultra extrovertiert ist, setzt man sich in die Mitte.
Echt, ernsthaft.
Ja.
Sie neigen dazu,
Dinge aufzuschieben,
bis nicht mehr.
Naja, ne, also
ich schiebe gerne
Dinge auf. Jaja, das stimmt.
Aber die wichtigsten Sachen kriege ich fertig.
Sie sind sehr
nervös in stressigen Situationen.
Ey, das kann ich nicht sagen. Es kommt
eigentlich nicht. Es kommt halt
auf die Situation an.
Also in stressigen Situationen
selbst, nein.
Da kann ich mich auch immer
zusammenreißen und nachzudenken.
In sehr stressigen Situationen, ja.
In sehr stressigen Situationen ist quasi neben dir
jetzt irgendwie die Rakete eingeschlagen.
Dann, äh, ich, äh.
Ja, machen wir mal so.
Äh, Heide
Guck mal, das muss ich mal gucken,
dass das richtig aussieht. Heide Kloba
Lelite.
Zwei Monate. Exzellent. Danke schön.
Für den Zapp.
Ok, äh, sie glauben, dass es
lohnenswerter ist, von anderen
gemocht zu werden, als einflussreich zu sein.
Boah,
boah, das ist...
Das ist schwierig.
Ich mein, ähm,
du kannst dir zwar nichts kaufen davon,
wenn dich
andere mögen.
Aber gerade auf YouTube
ist es nun mal so, dass
das da und also das
das da und das da
äh, ziemlich Hand in Hand gehen, ja.
Also sprich,
du musst auf YouTube
mehr oder weniger gemocht werden, dass du einflussreich wirst.
Aber insgesamt
boah, keine Ahnung.
Wir halten jetzt nichts zu ein.
Nee, ganz ehrlich, also wenn ich
jetzt mal so rein Bauchgefühl
mäßig sagen würde, würde ich sagen,
ähm,
also von anderen gemocht werden, finde ich,
ist jetzt ein doofes Wort.
Ich glaube,
man hat ein,
ich glaube, weiß ich, ob man sagen kann, erfüllteres Leben.
Wenn man nicht,
sag mal so,
wenn man ein bisschen vielleicht,
wenn man ein bisschen Kohle hat oder sonst was,
wenn man da auch andere dran teilhaben lässt.
Wenn man zum Beispiel irgendwas ans Tierheim spendet oder sonst was.
Also, ansonsten aber
auf die Sache, ich kann es echt schlecht beantworten.
Sie haben
sich schon immer für unkonventionelle
und mehr deutige Dinge interessiert.
Ja, das stimmt.
In gesellschaftlichen Situationen
ergreifen sie
oft die Initiative. Nein, mache ich nicht.
Nur wenn es mir zu sehr auf den Sack geht.
Die Frage ist eher, bist du netter Arbeitskollege oder der Boss?
Dann bin ich, äh,
ich versuche das meistens gut auszukommen.
Also ja, das stimmt, wenn man das so sieht,
wenn man das so sieht,
dann ist das so, weil ich habe keinerlei
Karriereambition.
Ich drück mich da immer um Sachen.
Ja. Ich hatte letztens einen Termin
mit einem, äh,
was war der?
Irgendwas,
das zweithöchste auf unserem Organikram.
Also ich letzte Woche einen Termin.
Ähm, weil
er gesagt hat, er ist neu
und möchte ein paar Sachen wissen und so. Weiß nicht,
wie er da überhaupt auf mich gekommen ist, mich da jetzt
einzuladen. Ähm,
da ist mir wieder eingefallen, dass
so eine Management-Hierarchie-Ebene
definitiv nichts für mich wäre.
Also ich ergreife gern die Initiative,
wenn es mir gar zu dumm wird.
Also wenn Leute
seit 30 Minuten versuchen,
was zu diskutieren
und nur Scheiße dabei rauskommt,
dann ja. Ansonsten
gehen mir gesellschaftliche Situationen komplett
am Arsch vorbei
und ich halte mich raus, solange es mich nicht
betrifft.
Okay.
Okay, Ergebnis, Ergebnis.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Virtuose!
Aha.
Virtuose
Istpa,
was auch immer das ist.
Okay, da ist sogar die Erklärung
unten drunter. Okay.
Virtuose.
Äh, okay.
Äh.
Virtuose lieben
es mit ihren Händen und ihren Augenzufangen, indem sie die
Welt um sich herum mit kühlem Verstand und
geistiger Neugierge berühren und untersuchen.
Menschen mit diesem Persönlichkeitstyp
sind natürliche Tatmenschen.
Äh,
ich weiß ja nicht.
Die ein Projekt nach dem, nein, ich weiß ja nicht!
Wie...
Was zum...
Nein!
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht!
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt weiß ich über mich Bescheid.
Super, virtuose.
Der große Philosoph.
Was für Zeug, aber.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Gandalf Sachs
Gan...
Sachs geil.
Über das Taschwasser.
Oh Mann.
Es gibt eh sau viele geile
äh, so kleine Filmchen
zu Herr der Ringe, wo sie irgendwas verarschen.
Die sind teilweise übelst lustig.
Okay, was kommens?
Coolest track ever.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich guck mir ja gerne Hardware von anderen Leuten an,
dass ich ein bisschen drüber abblästern kann.
Ach Moment, Airconditioning,
das ist ja langweilig.
Das ist ja...
Moment Freunde, der baut eine Klimaanlage
in seinen Rack ein, das ist ja...
Das ist ja langweilig.
Das kann ja jeder.
Es macht nur nicht jeder, weil es eigentlich
meistens überhaupt nicht notwendig ist.
Der will's aber daheim
echt wissen, ne? Der will's daheim
nicht wissen.
Wie gesagt, also...
Bei einem Rack sieht ja
mittlerweile immer noch mehr oder weniger so aus,
wie hier im Video. Wenn die Tür zu ist,
hier ist keine Klimaanlage drin und auch
im Sommer ist es hier relativ warm drin.
Aber cool genug, dass es
der Hard Fenix ausmacht.
Ich...
Ich will jetzt ein bisschen
lästern über Hardware, nicht...
Homeserver, ich will jetzt ein bisschen
lästern über Hardware von anderen Leuten.
Was hat der hier?
Ah!
Gute Bosch Agro Schrauber.
Und dann...
Das sieht ja aus wie 1995 von der Kameraqualität 4 zu 3 ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Aber gut, das ist von 1995 oder so.
Ich hatte eine CD-ROM-Tour mit 7 CD-ROM-Driven in der Kameraqualität und einer von diesen war ein Burner und das war primärlich wo ich die meisten meines Files an der Zeit störte, aber wie du dir vorstellen kannst, mit mehr und mehr digitalen Videos zu stören, war es wirklich nicht mehr so langweilig.
Okay, wo geht's los? Hey Max, hast du VODs auf Twitch, wo du etwas mit dem Raspberry Pi gemacht hast? Ja, wir haben alle VODs im Archiv und ich habe auch sehr viele VODs mit dem Raspberry Pi, aber da musst du mal durchgucken. Also ja, sau viele, wir haben bestimmt, keine Ahnung, schon 100 Streams gemacht mit dem Raspberry Pi in Verbindung.
Also jetzt zeigt das hier.
Jede Menge Netgear-Dinger, kann man die Auflösung noch ein bisschen hoch machen? Nee.
Okay, was hat er? Erstmal unten hat man hier die schönen Kokona-Steckdosen.
Das ist so, wobei ist das die Kokona? Das ist gar nicht die Kokona-Steckdose, oder? Die Kokona-Steckdose hat doch nur zwei, zwei Schlitze. Ist das die kanadische Steckdose? Was ist das für eine Steckdose, Leute? Oder ist es doch die Kokona-Steckdose?
Es könnte wirklich eine NA-Steckdose sein. Die sieht wirklich sehr erschrocken aus, ja? Jaja, es hat wirklich was hier vorne.
US-Steckdose, okay. Was hat denn hier irgendeinen Kabelmodem? Einige Switche am Start, Steckdosenleisten, keine Ahnung. Telefon oder so? Telefonanlage oder sowas? Ich erkenne es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau. PoE-Switch?
Gut, nichts allzu spektakuläres.
Zwei Monate, danke schön. Exzellent.
Komm, ich will mehr sehen hier.
Ja, 100? Das ist ja aus dem letzten Jahr 1000. 100. 100 MBit. Das ist ja richtig Monarch-S. Okay, kommt da noch ein bisschen mehr hier jetzt?
Da kommt aber wenig jetzt. Also er zeigt irgendwie sein Nass, okay. Das ist aber, da kann ich gar nicht so viel zu sagen, weil das Setup, was der hat, macht einen wirklich angemessenen Gesamteindruck. Nicht so die Leute, die irgendwie drei Racks daheim stehen haben.
Okay, dann mecke ich heute nicht über die Hardware anderer Leute. Ich ja gerne über die Hardware anderer Leute mecke.
German-Deutsch. Das war richtig schön im Keller.
OlleHP-Kisten. Das ist aber richtig alt. Ach 2016 ist das Video. Okay, wir können Battlefield-Topplays gucken. Wir können das hier gucken.
TrueOfMyHomeNetwork. Da haben wir doch noch irgendwas. Exzellent. Da kann ich doch noch ein bisschen über Hardware meckern.
Wofür brauche ich ein Smart-Switch? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Also Smart-Switch, das Wort gibt es an sich. Also wüsste ich nicht, ob das näher definiert ist. Was du meinst, ist wahrscheinlich ein Switch, den man managen kann.
Also sprich, der vielleicht Web-Interface hat, ein Kommando-Zeit oder sonst was, wo ich Einstellungen dran vornehmen kann. Ich gerne dann auch so was wie VLANs kann oder manche Switches können ja mittlerweile auch IP-mäßig irgendwas Portfilter machen oder so. Die ganzen Mikrotik-Switches können zum Beispiel IP-Sachen machen, auch wenn auch nicht sonderlich schnell wohlgemerkt.
Das nimmst du, wenn dir ein normaler Switch nicht reicht. Zum Beispiel, weil du VLAN-Settings machen musst oder ein normaler Unmanaged-Switch, den schließt du halt an und der switcht und sonst nichts. Du kannst da nichts einstellen.
Die meisten Managed-Switches, das fängt dann an mit VLAN-Geschichten, geht weiter, dass du vielleicht noch verschiedene Bridge-Interfaces zusammenpritschen kannst, was auch immer. Also Port-Aggregation machen und alle möglichen Sachen.
Also wenn du sowas machen willst, dann brauchst du einen Switch, mit dem du der Managed ist und der die passenden Features hat. Willst du das nicht machen, dann brauchst du das auch nicht.
So, wo ist sein Rack? Wow. Okay. What the fuck? Der willst daheim aber echt wissen, hier mit Glasfaser-Zeug. Nicht schlecht. Was ist denn das? Ist das die USB? Nee, was ist das? Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Er hat die hoch... Ey! Exakt so hatten wir früher die Switche in unseren Technikräumen auf der Arbeit hängen. Hochkant. Deswegen haben die damals den Felix und mich immer, als wir unsere Ausbildung noch gemacht haben, den Felix und mich in diese Technikräume geschickt, weil wir die einzigen zwei Klamotten haben.
Damals, dass wir da durchgepasst haben vor den Switches. Ich meine nur, dass wir halt irgendwie so acht Stück nach vorne hängen hatten. Und der Raum hier fertig war. Und wir waren die einzigen, die durchgepasst haben. Die anderen waren alle zu tief.
This room has changed a lot too. I now run my entire network on Ubiquiti UniFi gear and I love it. My core switch is a UniFi US XG16.
This is where all of my server gear plugs in or anything that needs 10 gigabit.
Moment, was hat der für ein?
This is where all of my server gear plugs in. My core switch is a UniFi US XG16.
Das ist der gleiche Switch, den ich habe. Nur, dass ich nicht die UniFi Variante gekauft habe, sondern die Edge Switch Variante. Das ist exakt der gleiche Switch, den ich habe. Nur die UniFi Variante. Guck mal.
UniFi ist vorne halt einfach silber und meiner ist schwarz vorne. Guck, das ist der gleiche Switch. Naja, Max hat die Klappe. Excellent. Max zeigt den Switch.
Ah, der da. Ja, das ist genau der gleiche Switch. Okay, er hat schon mal gute Switch sich ausgesucht.
This is where all of my server gear plugs in or anything that needs 10 gigabit.
My access switch is a UniFi USW Pro 48 Gen 2. My access switch is a UniFi USW Pro 48 Gen 2.
Gehäuse, Gehäuse, Gehäuse ist das da. Das ist das Gehäuse.
Und was gut an dem Gehäuse ist, du kannst hier Laufwerke rein machen und hier Laufwerke rein machen, den Lüfter von da nach da oder den Lüfter komplett raus machen. Ich habe hier in der Mitte den Noctua Lüfter reingemacht und das Beste ist, die liefern Staubfilter mit, was nun wirklich für Servergehäuse sehr selten ist.
Ich kenne außerdem, habe ich noch nie ein anderes Servergehäuse in der Hand gehabt mit einem Staubfilter. Noch nie. Welche Distro benutzt du eigentlich, Windows 10?
Okay, ich weiß, dass du das nicht meinst. Ich benutze mal ein Jaro mit i3WM.
Ja, gute Switch-Auswahl. Da kann ich das so approven.
Wenn ihr das so seht, vielleicht verstehen die einen oder anderen jetzt auch, warum ich da an sich bin, dass Rundgang im dunklen Rechenzentrum irgendwas Weihnachtliches hat.
Stellt euch mal vor, einen kompletten Raum mit blauen, grün und roten LEDs, die unterschiedlich blinken.
Das würde ich nicht mit einem UniFi-Switch machen. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich mit irgendeinem MikroTik-Switch machen.
Ja, das habe ich auch so.
Kann man machen, bin ich mittlerweile von weg. Ich mache das über meinen MikroTik-Router. Der hat ein paar IP-Filter-Regeln drin. Das reicht mir an Firewall.
Ganz ehrlich, was braucht man da großartig im Heimbereich? Einfach verbieten von einem Netz ins andere oder erst gar nicht erlauben.
Und ein paar Blocks, ein paar Block-Regeln für das China-IoT-WLAN. Ansonsten, fertig. Ich habe insgesamt vielleicht 15 Firewall-Regeln.
Die wichtigste Regel, die man nicht vergessen darf, ist, internes Netz ganz oben allow all, weil ansonsten sperrt man es nicht manchmal aus.
Die wichtigste Regel, die man nicht manchmal aus.